do see a record button on my screen I
did see a record button so theoretically
I could be doing that right and what but
the key thing was to go on on my notes
was to say that we're going on uh on the
cloud don't see a record button on my
screen I did see a record button so
theoretically I could be doing that oh
now I can hear myself oh my
God okay so all right let's go let's
start out with the my script here
okay as chair of the house Commerce and
consumer affairs committee I find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the co9
pandemic in accordance with the house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 2020-4 this public body is
authorized to meet electronically this
is a public hearing on bills referred to
the committee and scheduled in the house
calendar for today an executive session
may be held on any bills referred to
this committee however this chair does
not exact anything on on the same day
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporar usly to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and the
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporar isly
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporar asly
listening listen and if necessary
participate in the meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice of this
meeting complies with house rules in RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
this meeting shall call
271-3600 or email
HCS ledge. state. n. Us in the event the
public is unable to access this meeting
the meeting will have to adjourn and be
rescheduled please note that all votes
that are taken during the meeting shall
be done by roll call vote and your face
must be present on the screen let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance with each member stating
their presence
uh presence yeah uh please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during the meeting which is required
on the right to no law so Mr clerk would
you go ahead with a roll
call okay roll
uh representative John Hunt
yes representative
John you're gonna have to help me with
your last name I apologize
pusk representative John
pusk you're supposed to say you're
here so will will imply that here means
no one's in the room with
you representative Jason
Osborne Representative Keith Ammon clerk
present no one's in the room
representative Max Adamson
here representative Bonnie ham here and
no one's in the room representative
Joseph
dma here and alone representative
Jeffrey
gon present and I am by myself
representative Don
Johnson in the room with
representative
vus
okay representative Paul Terry president
and I'm here in
solitary representative chrisy
Bartlett here and I am in the room
alone represent representative Richard
Abel here and I'm at home by
myself representative Chris
heret president and I'm alone
representative Connie
hooton van hton I'm here alone and I am
present van hton
present representative Tina
Fargo I'm present and I'm here
alone representative Joyce Weston I'm
here and I'm by
myself representative Jane
bellu I'm here at home and uh my friend
Jack is in the house with me
representative Anita burough I'm here
alone uh downstairs but my husband's in
the
house representative Chris M McClair uh
Chris Maier I'm here my wife is in the
house but she is
leaving Maier I I will do my best to get
everyone's names uh correct uh please
forgive me a few times and I'll I'll
eventually get
it
that's the role Mr all right thank you
thank you very much and yeah I forgot to
mention I am alone okay um uh I don't
know there anything else I need to do so
let's why don't we just get going um so
we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill
610 uh and even though I am the prime
sponsor I am presenting this this bill
is in in request of the banking
department so I will have the banking
Department testify so that means I have
to go over to my attendees
and um I guess uh Kiera you're the first
one to speak so do you mind just raising
your hand Kier that way I oh I see now I
see you okay and so I'm going to click
on well I was allowed to talk I want to
have you allowed to speak to see you all
right I'm promoting you to a panelist
now so you're now a panelist
Kira
and are you are you on
did I yes she's here okay so you might
be muted
Kira yeah I I don't see a picture there
we go sorry I've now unmuted I'm sorry I
don't have a picture because my um
internet connectivity doesn't um seem to
like me when I put on my um audio and
video so I'm sorry I'll just be speaking
today and you won't get to see me okay
thank so thank you so much for um
allowing me to testify on House Bill uh
610 we at the department call this our
fiscal efficiency Bill the changes are
requested uh we're hoping to improve the
regulation of trust companies eliminate
waste and inefficiencies reduce costs
associated with various regulatory
processes and more equitably allocate
those costs uh there are a number of
changes in the bill and um if you look
at your the bill itself there's an
analysis section the very top um that
sort of lays out a description of the
changes that are
requested um and so what I've done in
the written testimony I provided to you
is I first placed each of those Roman
numerals um from the bill analysis in
the uh table and then I added some
bullet points to provide some further um
explanation so I've done this in the
order of the bill sections and I've
referenced the bill sections I'm hoping
that helps you follow along um so first
first uh we're requesting a change to
require all of our lienes to license and
file reports through the through the
nmls system um this is a system
electronic system that we currently have
all of our mortgage industry licenses
using um but we maintain a dual
licensing uh system for folks who don't
license through nmls what we're asking
for is to require all lenses to use the
nmls system that'll eliminate the Dual
systems that we currently have to
maintain and operate um we're going to
be uh asking for this change for um
currently retail sellers sales finance
companies small own lenders debt
adjusters and money transmitters last
session we asked for these changes for
the money transmitters but that um Bill
hb1 1437 got caught up in the Omnibus
bills that were vetoed so it
unfortunately didn't
pass um so those are bills sections 1
through 50 to make all those changes
happen next in sections 16 through 19 um
we're we're asking again to have the
provisions that were um put forward last
session in HB
1695 um incorporated into law um 1695
from last session was a result of the
Senate Bill 98 study committee
addressing trust companies um so these
requirements would uh add a requirement
in law that would have new trust
directors submit to a background check
it would give the commissioner authority
to remove directors or officers of trust
companies and Family Trust companies if
needed um I would note that the analysis
um references that the provisions would
be applicable to both TR applicable for
the background check to trust officers
it should actually read to trust
directors but the removal Provisions
apply to both directors and officers so
just the analysis SE
um that Roman numeral description was a
little off just wanted to make that
point but the bill itself is
correct um and then section 20 um again
is another provision that was put
forward in uh last session that was HB
1696 again as a result of the Senate
Bill 98 study committee this proposal
would increase the fee for uh filing an
application to Charter a new Trust
Company bank or credit Union it
increases that fee from $10,000 to
$155,000 and also authorizes the
commissioner to charge additional uh
fees costs uh for reviewing more
complicated
applications um we did have one change
from last sessions language in 1696
which was made at the request of
Industry Representatives um just to
clarify the process uh by which we
notify them that additional charges may
be incurred um
section
21 addresses assessments uh we uh on
occasion have uh entities that are
charted in New Hampshire and they either
uh close close their doors they dissolve
or they convert from State Charter to
Federal Charter um currently we have the
authority to assess those institutions
but sometimes the transition from State
Charter to Federal Charter or their
dissolution happens before we've had a
chance to actually issue the invoice for
the assessment so we're just trying to
clarify the law to give um some some um
additional um requirements that will
allow the commissioner to work with
those companies to collect that
assessment and then finally um in
section 22 or so not finally we've got a
few more in section 22 we're asking to
have the interest rates that are used
for um payment uh of interest on escro
accounts that um pay the taxes and um
Insurance on
mortgages um we're asking to have that
interest rate tied to the federal funds
interest rate currently we calculate
that interest rate and we have to ask
twice a year ask the depository Banks to
submit information to allow us to
develop that rate by tying it to federal
funds interest rates we don't have to do
that calculation and the banks can uh go
directly to that federal funds website
um uh Open Market Committee website and
get that interest rate
themselves and then finally um sections
23 through 28 um this is a provision
that was again put forward last session
that was an HB
1437 that bill was also caught up in the
Omnibus bills in vetto but the
provisions would allow us to transmit
consumer complaints via email rather
than uh through snail mail U certified
post office mail um we really have
especially with Co had a difficult time
managing uh to mail out these letters
with post office issues they don't get
delivered and sometimes it takes weeks
and weeks for us to get a complaint to a
leny um so we would like the ability to
send them by email which is much more
efficient um allows us to ensure that
the entity has received that email same
day with with the the the um ability for
using receipt received um options and
Outlook that we have so we're asking for
these changes to be put in place and
this would affect all of our both
licensed and chartered
institutions so those are all the
changes um that we're requesting and I'm
happy to answer any questions and I have
with me uh other folks from the
Department who are much more
knowledgeable about these provisions and
can answer more specific questions that
I can't okay well we have one raised
hand uh representative Terry uh you got
to First unmute yourself there you go uh
first a question for you Mr chair um I
requested a packet uh of bills that were
going to be considered today be mailed
to me and the packet was mailed on the
22nd and I'm not seeing Bill number 610
in the packet bill so I'm at a distinct
disadvantage here being able to
participate with respect to the
discussion and consideration of this
bill wondering how I can access that and
then second Mr chairman if I may ask a
question of Miss doino once you respond
to me okay so yeah so if um I I assume
you only have one computer but uh you do
need to pull up if you pull up your uh
search engine uh and go into the House
of
Representatives and in House of
Representatives there are several ways
to go find bills um I usually go to the
committee and then say bills that are in
the committee but right on that front
screen it'll say ask you for a bill
number so if you type in hb610 it should
pop right up for you okay I'll um I'll
get up my other computer here and um
better I'll be ambidextrous okay I will
well you I'll leave your hand up knowing
F Well that you have a question or do
you want to ask that question now I'd
like yeah may I ask that question
certainly if I may uh and I'm sorry uh
Miss doino I am unable to specify
exactly when and where you referenced a
proposed fee increase from $10,000 to
$15,000 yes that was a a provision that
was put forward last year uh it affects
trust companies Banks and Credit Unions
that are seeking to be chartered in New
Hampshire um those changes were uh
worked out as a result of the Senate
Bill 98 study committee um and currently
the fee is $10,000 to Charter a new bank
credit union or trust company and that
um is increasing from $10,000 to
$15,000 so if I uh question you may
inquire so if I may thank you uh thank
you
sir uh what apparently the fate of the
request last year died or was rejected
if you could speak to the history of
that from the last session I would
appreciate it as a new member and second
with respect and second if I may with
respect to the
increase uh since we're talking about a
state function um how does the current
and how does the proposed fee compare to
other
states um the same service right I
honestly don't know what the other
states charge but perhaps giving you a
little more information about how the
banking department works and how we
funded might be helpful um the banking
department is not General funded um in
that at the end of each year we use um a
calculation to determine if the fees
we've collected cover all of the
operating costs of the department if
they don't we impose an assessment and
then all of our chartered institutions
kick in and pay that assessment so by
increasing the fee what we're hoping to
do is capture the actual work involved
in reviewing those trust um and Bank Etc
applications that are filed if we don't
capture the cost of reviewing the
application from the applicant then the
rest of the institutions um foot the
bill and pay more in the assessment so
it's really uh more of a cost shifting
from um what we're trying to accomplish
is have the institution filing the
application pay the the cost for us
reviewing that application as opposed to
pushing the cost onto the assessment and
the other
institutions um I can look and find out
what the other states May charge for
similar applications if that would be
helpful um I don't have that information
right now
Mr chairman one one last followup yes uh
thank you uh Miss doino um would you do
so please with res respect to your offer
to to look at um other states and what
they charge for a comparable service um
and uh given uh a time and perhaps
staffing issues I would be satisfied if
um if if you would do so for uh New York
and the New England states I don't see
any reason personally for me to uh to
have you do a 50 state survey but
regionally New York and and the New
England states I would appreciate that
if You' get that to me thank you thank
you chairman okay if you're all set then
just drop your hand or I guess I can can
I drop you low I'm lowering your hand
okay uh representative
Bartlett thank you um I just wanted to
point out that last night when I went
through all the bills there were a few
missing um so going to the um website of
the general court and making sure your
bills are there and just print out what
might be missing would help us um all
when we're when we're ready for um
committee
day any anything else all right I'm
going to drop your hand okay and
representative
AEL you are
muted thank you um there's a category of
uh large family trusts uh some that are
foreign uh or I should say alien being
outside the United States I wonder if
this affects them or are they Exempted
from any of the changes here uh they are
not exempt from the changes um the
changes that would affect trust
companies um let me just go through it
methodically the background check would
apply to them for the new directors
um the assessment would apply to them
where we're seeking to um collect the
assessment if they were to um
dissolve um and the um complaint
Provisions I think would apply to them
as well so yes it applies consistently
to any of our charted institutions
family or or or um non-family trust
companies and if that's um I'll go back
and double check that if that's
incorrect I'll I'll certainly let you
know but I do believe applies to those
folks okay uh anybody else have any
questions I um I would be remissive I
didn't uh point out that um I did have a
phone call um from the Auto Dealers
Association and they're a little
concerned about um the the
notification uh because they're used to
getting the notification by certified
mail and they're worried about being
sent an email and having it end up in
their in their junk box
um but I I would I would hope that
because they're in the sales business
they don't have too much there in their
junk that that they're always like me um
I never know when I consist when sends
me a letter sends me an email I have to
I I so I did did away with my my junk uh
sorry just because it it I I've got to
be able to see see everything so could
you respond to that concern um about how
we make sure that that dealers uh uh or
anybody uh if we're sending it to them
by email that they will make sure they
actually get it in a timely fashion yes
so um first of all when you become
licensed through the department you're
required to provide us with contact
information so that we can get in touch
um we often need to reach out to a
license e uh obviously if there's a
Consumer complaint if we need to discuss
with them some concern we may have um
setting up examinations Etc so as part
of the licensing process there required
to give us uh contact information and
they're also required by law to update
that information um at any time so if
their contact information changes they
need to give us that um we have not had
any issues with reaching Folks by email
we have had issues reaching Folks by
certified mail through the post office
we've had those uh certified mailings
come back uh with email it's much easier
to find that to to confirm that
someone's received the email um so we
have not had the issue with the email I
understand that there are concerns there
are a whole host of ways to address
those on the The lenses end uh first of
all of course to keep keep the contact
information updated um but in addition
if they add the banking Department to
their contact um uh contacts then we
won't get stuck in the spam um and there
are other things that they can do they
can create a um consistent email address
that multiple people access just in case
someone's on vacation then other people
will be checking the email there's
there's a whole host of wonderful
technological solutions to these issues
and um we're certainly willing to work
with our
lenes um if we send an email and we
don't hear back we we are always
reaching back out and trying to contact
them so I don't think in in real terms
this is going to be an issue for
them okay uh representative Abel you
have your hand back up again oh I'm
sorry
okay is there anyone else that has any
other
questions represent uh uh I don't even
see see you on my okay did you raise
your oh that's right because I can't see
you raise your hand because you're in
the committee room right and I can't see
610 okay representative Johnson do you
have a question yes I
do go ahead my question is on the
beginning talking about it being finance
loans debors and stuff and so forth but
what do you mean and and can you clarify
retail
sellers because when I think of a retail
seller that is you know a clothing
store right so
I sorry this this is a clerk I'm not
able to understand what was just said so
uh representative Johnson is asking what
is a retail seller if I is that correct
represented Johnson right because when I
anybody else is right so what is the
definition of retail seller when we come
to the banking statute yeah okay
representative sure attorney Doo yes yes
so the retail sellers are the folks that
basically are the car dealerships that
are helping to arrange the financing um
using a retail installment contract they
help the consumer uh they you know have
there with the consumer when the
consumer buys a car helps them fill out
the loan application and then ultimately
that loan is transferred to the lender
so that is your your retail seller thank
you app okay so just so we let's make
sure we all understand this um uh so uh
when I was in the computer retail
business I used to help we used to help
people get uh uh ge financing to buy a
computer um I'm I'm a in the retail
business do I have to register with the
banking Department no the retail sellers
that we're talking about are the folks
that are just selling cars we don't
regulate other folks that help arrange
financing for buying sofas or other
things like that we're just talking
about your your car dealerships so
statutorily it was just narrow to only
car dealers who have to pay this $50 a
year uh registration
fee the those are the folks that have to
license to the department and we
regulate them because they're working
with the consumers on the financing
applications and and so the the law
requires those folks to be licensed with
us okay great are there any other
questions so I guess guess I'll have to
pay attention of that 610 Square I don't
know how have to figure out to do that
chair person chairperson hunt
representative U MC mckel has had his
hand up for quite a
while really I I don't I don't see it on
my screen here but go ahead um a a
question uh m doino how do how do you
defined a Family
Trust what what exactly how far down the
line does that go so a Family Trust
Company is a specific type of Trust
Company um that I'm going to pull up the
law right now just so I'm not going to
misspeak um and I can give you the
actual definition but these are trust
companies that are formed by a family um
in order to manage the wealth of that
family um so let me see here hang on
just a second I'm going to give you the
official statutory
definition which I'm sure is going to be
incredibly clear to
everyone give you a little Side Story uh
represent so this is actually one of our
Le newest of our trust different kind of
trust legislation um many many years ago
um I sponsored the original trust
statute uh and uh so that we bring to
bring us competitively to other states
in terms of how we have our banking our
Bank and Trust TR law set up um over the
years different things have created and
these these new family trusts are a new
kind of a new item um and we we we
created a study committee because we
wanted to make sure that that uh how we
were regulating them and how we were
feing their fees were is done correctly
and some of this legislation is actually
driven by that study committee um but uh
but um you can go ahead now
representative excuse me attorney doino
so when un fortunately the definition is
not helpful at all um a Family Trust
Company is a trust company that is
organized organized under the laws of
this state and authorized to engage in
trust business under
members they don't interact with the
public um and you have to be related by
a certain number of degrees to the
family member that creates the Trust
Company um generally these Family Trust
companies are really only practical for
folks with very significant wealth um
you're not going to be setting up a
Family Trust Company you know unless you
have well unless you win the lottery or
have a whole lot of money let's put it
that
way and then you know this was some
country because said it wasn't that
they're necessarily going to be New
Hampshire citizens and that we were
going to draw you know H out but they
draw more wealth to the state of
Hampshire that we could be taxable and
interested in so this uh they brought up
a lot of different issues around this
this particular subject the Family Trust
um so we certainly can spend a little
more time in helping you get your arms
around it um but yes go ahead for the
question oh so in other words if if I'm
the trustee of of my mother's trust and
I'm just dispersing the assets this has
nothing to do with that absolutely
nothing nothing that is correct glad you
asked that question okay now I'm looking
for more hands up you
know I don't see any other hands up
unless anybody knows so know something
let me help me out otherwise uh I will
um well before I close the hearing I'll
read the uh the blue sheet which is
people who uh have signed up either for
against the bill and have duly noted so
um I have uh Todd Wells uh who's from
the banking Department in support I have
uh Nancy dagel from the banking
Department also and uh um oh I see they
don't take positions so excuse me no no
positions uh oh testifying no that's
position is support but not tesy okay I
got to get used to the screen okay uh
and then Ren sh so all these people were
in the are all online of visiting us
from the banking department they also
support the bill um Amilia gardi um is
also from the banking Department in
support of the bill and of course we
have the commissioner Jerry little is uh
online and supports we have John Daly
who's a member of the public who's
opposed to the
bill uh but did not ask to be speaking
uh Tom parasol um who is the Mortgage
Bankers and Brokers Association in New
Hampshire who are regulated by us um
supports the bill we have Dave Collins U
who's also a lobbyist who represents New
Hampshire Credit Unions and they're in
support of the bill we have Glenn Perlo
um he's a lobbyist and he does he does
the a lot of the Family Trust business
and he's in Hampshire trust Council and
he in support of the bill and then
finally Ryan hail from the New Hampshire
Bankers Association who's in support of
the bill and having nobody else um I
will close the public hearing on House
Bill 610
okay no gavel but uh sound like somebody
did that did you do that for me John you
hit that
gavl okay so what time is our next bill
what did I
G next bill is at 9:30 so you're right
on time it's right on time okay okay and
look at that some the HB 312 so our Tech
that's in the committee room is on on
Johnny on the spot also so I don't have
to tell everybody all right we'll open
up me by the way just so you know oh
that's you who's doing that oh cool cool
because that's a new future I didn't
know that was coming but that's our
that's our substitute for for allows
everybody to see what Bill we're on if
they should come into the and wonder if
you're running late or right that's you
know because I thought I had sort of be
like a uh the radio talk show to keep
telling people what station we're on so
right but anyway it's great so you're
doing it for me all right so we'll open
up the house bill uh 312
and which is the other banking
Department Bill and we'll hear from
Kiera Delino again um uh and who will
and present the bill for us thank you so
the written testimony I provided you a
follows the same format as the prior
bill um hb610 I've pasted from the bill
uh analysis the Roman numerals that are
found there and then provided some
further clarification and identified the
bills sections affected so um HP 312 is
what we would call our clarifications
bill it applies to both uh the
provisions herein apply to both
chartered and licensed entities um and
we're making adjustments that we feel
will help clarify existing statutes make
them less confusing um help formalize
long-standing interpretation of our laws
or will eliminate Provisions that are
obsolete or
unnecessary so um to go through each of
the sections um the first part of the
bill sections 1 through five and then
section 13 at the end are amendments
that will help further um clarify the
deadlines that apply to examinations of
our Consumer Credit
licenses um currently the law as written
is not that clear so we've proposed
amendments to make the deadlines for
those folks to submit documents and
information to us more clear and to give
them a slightly longer period of time to
provide that information we're also
asking for a slight change to um chapter
399 G which applies to money
transmitters so that the provisions
related to production of documents and
examinations mirror the other Consumer
Credit chapters for some reason uh the
provisions were sort of out of
sequence um in section six we're asking
for a change um that's been necessitated
by covid uh with covid we have mortgage
loan Originators who are now teleworking
from their personal residents Uh current
law may requ seem to require them to be
licensed in their state of residence
even if they're not working with
consumers in that state uh so we want to
amend the law so that they're not
required to be licensed in their home
state if they're working from
home section seven applies to Family
Trust companies um currently we examine
all chartered instit institutions uh
Family Trust companies banks credit
unions Etc we have specific Provisions
that state the commissioner can examine
entities more frequently than every 36
months or whatever the applicable time
frame is um we are asking to have the
same language added for the Family Trust
Company examinations we think it was
just an oversight that they weren't in
there um and so this will bring those
folks in line with the other chartered
institutions next in sections 8 through1
we're asking for clarification that
depository Banks can elect to operate as
a benefit Corporation under
293c we have currently two banks that
have elected that status and we just
want to incorporate um clear language in
the statute to authorize
that in section 11 we're having asking
for clarifications to the provisions
that apply to credit unions and um the
Del ation by Credit Union boards to
committees we just want to clarify that
um the the the credit union board still
has an obligation to oversee the work of
the committee and review minutes um
these Provisions that we're seeking are
identical to the ones that already exist
in laws applicable to
Banks and then finally in section 12 um
this is a change that we requested back
in the 2020 session in hb1
1437 um and they adjust the restrictions
that apply to just the commissioner and
Deputy Commissioner as to the types of
loans and other Financial transactions
that they can engage in um we want to
modernize our existing law so it
conforms to um you know the state ethics
code that's now in place um essentially
it would allow um our commissioner
Deputy Commissioner to finance a loan to
purchase a vehicle a mortgage on their
home Etc as long as those mortgage and
those other Financial transactions are
all um consistent with the ethics
requirements and are done in the normal
course of
business so those are all the provisions
in this bill HB 312 and I'm happy to
answer any
questions okay uh so if you want to ask
a question please raise your hand oh
Chrissy was there but not uh okay re
representive van
hton
uh you you do I have to unmute I'm all
said thank you very much and thank you
attorney doino I have just a couple of
quick questions one is just a
grammatical question I guess um I'm
looking at Roman
2B that's on page two of the document
that I have uh it begins failure to
provide files and
documents and it appears that there's
been an effort throughout this to change
that and that and
or right um the request that goes out um
to the
lensee uh sometimes asks for them to
provide actual documents sometimes it
asks them to ask them to to provide
consumer loan files and other similar
files um those are terms of art with our
examiners and with our lienes so we
wanted to try to make make it clear um
that it's or not and for those types of
documents or files followup please
further question may inquire so I I'm
assuming that that and should be changed
to or based upon what you've just said
am I correct yes and we did I thought we
did attempt to make those changes in all
the sections affected thank you followup
please yes for the question in the last
section on Bank commissioner
qualifications I I know we've had
legislation that that talked about this
in the past but I still would just like
to mention my concerns about the
qualification that includes um fails to
become resident of the state within one
year after his or her appointment I
still see that as something that's very
difficult to follow up on and to make
sure that we have ascertained that uh
after a commissioner is named so that's
just a comment about something that I'm
uncomfortable with that I've always been
uncomfortable with thank
you I would say in my 30 some years Bank
commissioner has always been
a resident so I guess this issue has
never come up but
um fair enough uh you can put your I'll
put your hand down for you
uh okay is there anybody else okay uh
Max representative abon has a question
don't can you folks hear me yes we can
um how would this bill if past affect uh
um individuals who have uh see business
or a home in a Family Trust are they
going to be affected by
this um I the only provision that would
really affect the Family Trust Company
is the provision where we're asking to
allow the commissioner to examine more
frequently than every 36 months if if
it's deemed necessary in current law the
commissioner can open an investigation
and conduct what we call a visitation at
any time so in Practical terms the
commissioner does have auth to step in
if if something arises that causes
concern and conduct essentially the
equivalent of an examination of that
Family Trust Company so um that would be
the only provision in here that would
directly affect a Family Trust Company
and again we think that under current
law essentially the same process could
occur yeah I I think I I know where
you're going with this maack so I as a
as a as a trust fund baby myself um I
there it is the word trust fund is
probably a misnomer here um yes these
are called trusts but but they're
nothing to do with uh your you know
trust funds that that those of us um who
are fortunate to have um they they're
not affected by this legislation
whatsoever is that is that where your
question is
going oh my question is not going
anywhere it's an open question oh okay
so do you do you feel satisfied or do
you have another question or followup no
that's fine okay great all right is
there anybody else looking for hands I
get I know the hands are supposed to pop
to the top but I don't know how I'm I
missed okay uh seeing no other
questions um and before I close the
hearing I will then read from the blue
sheet and we do have a couple more
people from the banking Department uh
ring shoot uh shoot was is in support of
the bill from the banking department and
Nancy Deo also from the banking
department is in support of the bill uh
and with that if there's nobody else
wants to speak we will close the public
hearing on House Bill
312 okay so now I'm ahead of schedule
but I just Mr yes I just wondered if
everybody understood how to raise their
hand uh yeah is everybody is there
everybody does everybody understand how
to do that there's a taskar on the
bottom okay con Connie just Connie was
testing us yes she put her hand up again
yes yes question yes okay so Connie
knows how to do it yes yes represent V
uh thank you I just want to ask um I
guess a point of order question yes how
do we go about submitting amendments now
that we do not have access fair fair
question okay so um I would ask
certainly this bill well the first one
we did and the next one we're about to
do are our two early
bills so those ones we want to get out
out of the committee in a timely fashion
I have actually scheduled every Bill
already on a on a on a per day basis but
that um I until they give me or give
give us a second day rather than just
Tuesdays because if we only met on
Tuesdays we would not be able to make
make their deadlines so we actually do
need another day of the week um and I'm
told that that there is a possibility we
won't get it for next week but we could
get it the following week so in that's
in any case what I did was in scheduling
bills is I put in an exec session uh at
1:15 so after lunch we would exact and
it's really 15 to 30 minutes um I'll be
frank with everyone if we get too deep
into needing to amend a bill or process
of a bill um then then um I will be
urging everybody to just retain the bill
and we'll take that up in in September
to really do our you know what this com
this committee has known for which is
get down and dirty and in subcommittee
having said that um I would urge um
anyone who uh in terms of any bills we
he if there is issues that you're you
care about or want to work on I would
urge you to contact me to let me
know that you have an amendment for it
or you would like to do an amendment or
you want to do talk about it so at that
point I can then plan in terms of
scheduling how we want to handle that
concern and like I say if it's you know
let's say if you just want to remove the
residency requirement okay that's a
pretty straightforward Amendment um we
could take that up at the time we are um
uh executing the bill because that's
pretty straightforward simple you know
concept um if we if we want to if we get
into a big long discussion and it's
clearly the committee is really torn on
it then I'll just say okay well let's
just retain the bill then and and work
work on it next year so I would hope
that when there if there are a little
minor tweaks and that and um that we can
fix the bill with um and again it's
become make me aware of it that you
you're concerned then I'll just have to
make sure I schedule time and figure out
how and how we can accomplish that does
that make
sense yes go ahead follow please no
thank you for that um and I think
there's that one little glitch of and
should be or for one thing and I am
considering that residency requirement
um and and just wondering about that
however what would be the procedure that
I would have to go through just to
inform you I don't have to go through
OSS and get a a drafted amendment to
bring forward well I mean informing me
would mean we have a conversation and
I'll try to talk you out of it or I try
to make sure I understand what your
issue is at that point um if it if it
does seem appropriate to have an
amendment drawn up then and I would
discuss it and we would then tell Pam
who just made herself visual Vis that uh
that we would have that Amendment drawn
up so that we would take it up when
we're executing the bill so did you want
to comment Pam yeah I thought I would
just add in it the process that was
actually established last year or maybe
even the year before where um ask ol at
le. state. n. us is is the process that
they started using you know before the
pandemic for submitting information
about um you know Amendment requests and
um mailing them back to you you know
emailing them back to you so we had
stopped the paper pickup process um and
so that will continue ask
OLS at l.st do. us Works notifying you
know asking me to help out absolutely
and and um conversations with the chair
so he knows what's going on all all
sense so I'm saying Connie that that if
you know obviously I'll you know
generate an opinion one way or the other
about the amendment but that the process
now is that we would then go through OS
and they would then email the amendment
to all the members and and um and then
we can figure out how we want to how we
want to dub tail it into the bill or
not okay maybe we can talk offline about
those two little glitchy things uh thank
you for the input and Pam thank you as
well thought all I thought the and or
they got on all but you're saying there
was one of them they didn't get there
was one and right it's I'm looking page
two line 15 yeah see you I don't have
those sheets I had to print mine
out okay but I know I see failure to
provide there's the one in deleted it's
the the new B in the middle of my page
that the first words are failure to
provide files and documents oh see on
mine mine the an is crossed
out really and I printed mine offline I
mean from from what's
online but am I I looking so after two
which is delivered to commissioner files
B failure to provide files and is
crossed out and says or documents within
time established by this paragraph s
subject a license year person to a fine
of $50 per day for each
day and and under Roman four I think
that's line Roman four is all crossed
out okay so now going down Roman 4 and
you're saying in the B of Roman four two
2 B 2B failure to provide files and do
with in the time establish by subject
turns into a fine of $50 per day after
20 each day the
files or documents are are not produced
so after you get the after 21 days is
deleted right
well but you have at the very beginning
of B failure to provide files and and
document okay I got okay so so yes so
we'll we'll have we'll have that
Amendment uh that that that Amendment
drawn up so Pam will take care of that
already Pam will Pam know knows about it
so she will make sure she'll take care
of it right Pam right just remove just
changing that one and to an or yeah
sorry I was looking at the wrong place
so that's the downside of not having
having the bills as printed from
the okay uh and I would just add Mr
chairman that one one reason is that not
all the bills were sent out was that not
all of them have come back from the
print shop yet okay so the scheduling
happened faster than the printing in
some cases and
um that's unfortunate right well I I
find myself I couldn't I couldn't be and
begin to scheduling bills until I had
printed out and as you remember P Pam in
the past in the old days I used to have
to lay them all out and figure out where
I G to do to match them up so okay
representative emam has a question yeah
I just have a technical question this is
my first time on the committee my first
time clerking yes and so what I'm
finding is there are terms that I'm not
familiar with and it takes me a little
while to process it so I can think about
what I'm supposed to type okay uh is
there a way we could slow things down a
little bit
um what do I do if I fall behind and I
and I need to catch up uh you just have
to you can just say Mr chair please hold
pause for a second um I I would say that
um that we're most of our bills won't
have these kind of technical language
and when we do the department bills and
and I guess we do have the insurance
department so they might get into the
same problem you know some uh but I I
will urge them to try to be when we get
to the insurance bills to the department
I'll tell them to tr to make sure that
we slow down when with new Concepts that
members of the committee might not be
familiar with right just to explain you
know what an acronym might mean or what
a certain term might me um that would be
helpful and then uh you press record on
this that's going to be available later
so yeah so for everybody just so you
know um all these sessions are available
right now even as we speak so if someone
else is not in the room they can go on
to YouTube and and and watch the
streaming um on the House of
Representatives web page uh YouTube page
and just go to Commerce and it should be
there and of course you can then
restream it anytime when as a clerk to
see what was said so you can do that
again also yeah great can't can't wait
to listen to the whole thing all over
you
yeah okay uh representative Abramson has
his hand up yes yes I just have a
comment it's it's on that fine it's on
page two and it's also on page three
line two and another on page three line
25 and so forth I'm just noticing the
it's just a $50 a day fine um and if
you're taking away that 21 day you know
after 21 days that looks like it'd be
about
$1,000 increase in in what people are
being fine but um the first thought that
comes to mind when I look at find for
credit unions and Banks and business and
whatnot is is this going to be born out
disproportionately on small business
versus Big Business um big business and
big companies sometimes will see a
really small fine on something and
they'll just totally just they'll
disregard the rule and just pay the pay
the fine every single day um but small
businesses and startups and people
trying to get uh get a brand new say
Credit Union um established uh they
don't have uh millions of dollars
sitting in the bank so to speak to uh to
cover they better they better have
millions of dollars in the
bank we uh both banking Insurance the
most important thing you need to know
under these institution is
solvency so we that's what their our
departments are making sure that they
are truly solvent and then that that
they can afford to do business so um
that's a critical item um I I you nobody
wants to drag out uh waiting to deal to
respond to the banking Department I I
don't think that this happens very often
so but I I hear your concern you know
let's make sure we don't hurt the the
little credit unions or the little Banks
but um believe in me they're they're all
in this together and they they want to
respond to the department as quickly as
possible at any rate uh we can certainly
think about that one uh is there anybody
else no I don't see any other in so
we'll close the public hearing on 3:12
you're supposed to write that Keith
write the time down I don't know if I
did yeah I've been keeping up with that
okay so we can close that now I guess
officially and then we have four minutes
before the next hearing so uh we can
take a a pause unless anybody has any
other questions they'd like to ask me
yeah representative um hunt Mr chairman
yes yes go Jane uh representative Bo
you're here um I I will be um leaving at
11: for a dentist appointment and then
I'll be back this afternoon but we'll
have to um leave at roughly about
2:15 okay I had some appointments that I
couldn't resched I I and I'm sure then
anybody has a vaccine date they're
gonna so no we're uh you know we
understand everybody comes and goes and
that's that's that's so feel comfortable
would say is um that that having that if
if someone wants to make sure they can
you can certainly U send a text to me
and my tech my phone number is on the
web page so anybody feel free to text me
if they want me to know that why they're
they're leaving um and obviously if
you're if your if your name disappears
from the screen then you're obviously
not in the room and uh but that um I
would ask people that if you do get up
uh to leave you know do turn your camera
off so you know we don't see necessarily
see an empty seat but um you know just
you know that how feel free to turn the
camera off um especially if you're
getting up from your seat sometimes you
know we it might be best that we didn't
see see what pants you were wearing that
day but um and should we leave should we
leave the meeting and then um log back
in uh once we get back um that's
probably the best thing to do okay I
think that's yeah uh because it's better
better for me to know you're not around
rather than see your name then go call
for you when you're not there and yeah
it's probably best so I'll take
attendance for each bill based on no I
wouldn't worry about that I I think the
attendance is just them you know morning
in but but we know full well that people
can come and go with attendance so the
form that the the house clerk gave me
has uh it has like an attendance uh list
for each bill really yeah I don't know
Pam am I really supposed are we supposed
to roll call it for each bill no that's
yeah not roll call but uh it says
he he said to like all the names are in
bold unbold the members names who were
not present and that's on each form for
each
bill Mr chair when I did the clerking I
did just visually update the the names
that were on the bill so that I I
actually did take attendance for each
individ that is true when we we would
always Circle when we were when we were
having a hearing we would Circle who was
there but no that's what it was for so
so yeah so that if the person is you
don't I don't know if you need to take a
roll call but
um yeah maybe maybe could could you let
me know uh yes I I let me follow up on
that to find out because you're not a
host so you wouldn't
necessarily but you're you can see all
the people who are there
right panelist right but I can see the
list of panelists I I can see a very
long list that I'll have to you know
sort through depending on how many
people are on call yeah right because
well everybody should have rep next to
their name so so yeah so so when you
start when we started hearing your
theoretically you should uh you know
Circle or in the old days we would
Circle it on the clerk's sheet but but
to to identify who's here who's not here
so
okay I I think doing that I I'll miss
some testimony but if uh people if
people could just let me know that
they're leaving that would also be
helpful yeah okay okay work that way all
right so now it's 10 o'clock
so uh I guess we'll open up the public
hearing um public hearing on the next
bill um just
uh okay so uh next bill is what are we
at
7 Bill 76 okay prohibiting paper billing
fees all right so You' you've updated
that I see that by renaming the room I
see that that Pam that you can then
identify that this we're now on to the
next bill okay so I would ask the um oh
Max you have your hand up is it you have
a question Max yeah I just wanted to
make a point on the the packets that I'm
also missing quite a few bills um come
from the printer yeah they didn't come
back from the printer yet um I also
noticed in the calendar that I've got a
a hearing at 120 where I've got to go
introduce a bill and we'll be um in
session right at that time amateur radio
antennas okay well we that we understand
all right so um I'm now going to go to
the 10d so um the sponsor uh raise your
hand
or okay okay there she is all right and
I am now going to promote you to
panelist
and we'll be rejoining the webinar is
that panelist so I think you're on are
you on yes I am thank you so much Mr
chair I do love your background though
thank you yes all right well thank you
um thank you members of the committee
I'm here today to introduce you the
house bill 76 FN prohibiting paper
billing fee as you can see this bill has
a strong bipartisan
sponsorship the growing trend of
business and credit card companies to
charge consumers for Pap billing has and
was brought to my attention by a
constituent who is retired in my
district I shared this constituent's
concern about how those fees penalize
people on a fixed income families
struggle to make ends meet people who
live in a rural area without Dependable
access to the internet and those who are
simply uncomfortable with the risk of
putting their financial information
online the pandemic has even made
household finances even harder for many
where every penny does count according
to the National Consumer League consumer
group in the United States Canada Europe
and Australia have all reported
increasing numbers of companies that
have begun charging customers who wish
to receive and mail in paper bills those
charges are often presented as quote
good news end quote by offering
discounts for quote going paperless end
quote some are going further by offering
additional discount to those who agree
to turn over banking information to
allow the companies to deduct their
charges directly from the consumer's
bank
account paperless billing is a good good
news for many people those who have a
computer stable internet and stable
income but not for
everyone it's not a good news for some
New Hampshire residents the National
Consumer League sites a typical paper
billing
charges nationally of $3.50 a month I
spoke with a New Hampshire family those
cell phone bills providers offer a $40
month $40 a month discount if they were
paperless and provided access to their
bank account for auto pay this is a
clearly a discriminatory a practice that
penalized those on a fixed income people
with access to the internet or computer
often low income citizens and honestly
any family working hard to meet their
many Financial
Obligations how many people can be sure
that their checking account balance will
be enough to cover one or more monthly
bills on a date that the business wants
to debit their account according to a
survey conducted by the research company
tuna USA 86% of America American
consumers believe that they should not
be charged more as a result of opting
for a paper bill I suggest if committee
members can contacted their own
constituents on this question they would
find a similar result this pandemic has
brought forth many studies and statistic
statistics on how many people do not do
not have adequate internet service on
article in the New Hampshire Business
Review stated that 45 to 55% of people
in many communities in New Hampshire
said they internet service was not
adequate for their
needs you might also be thinking of
environment and that avoiding paper
billing saves trees truthfully a
minority of New Hampshire residents will
likely opt in for this
service an infot Trend study showed
about 25% of people will op in for the
paper they do this for a certain type of
bills such as medical bills where
privacy is important and for other bills
not for all of them we should be
thinking of those who need the service
once your private records are on the
internet and perhaps fall into the wrong
hands are compro compromised or hacked
into it can take years to repair your
credit history and you might suffer
identity theft and never feel quite safe
again having an alternative option for
New Hampshire residents is ideal
finances are not the only reason for
opting for paper often is for privacy
reasons as the case of those who wants
to keep their medical records private my
informal research show that a number of
thriving New Hampshire utilities which
are which are of course in a different
category such as eversource and TDS
Telecom do not charge extra for paper
billing they understand the needs this
also tells me that they likely face no
substantial hardship from continuing to
offer customers their own free choice
when it comes to billing method without
charging a penalties I hope you like I
hope you will keep those points in mind
and choose to vote in favor of the house
will 7 6 FN and act prohibiting paper
billing fees it's a very simple step we
can take in a bipar and way to provide a
great and necessary benefit to our
constituents and to the people of our
state thank you so much Mr speaker thank
you and I assume you're ready you're
willing to take questions sure I'll take
a question okay can I can I interject
this is the clerk uh yes uh
representative Ward would you or have
you submitted uh written testimony yes I
have last night okay thank you great
okay so representative van Hon's first
up thank you very much thank you
representative uh for bringing this and
for taking my questions I actually have
two quick ones I noted that between last
year's Bill and this year's bill you
added the clause for paying by mail does
that seem to be becoming a greater
problem are more people charging for
those who pay by mail
yes that is one of the reasons that I'm
proposing this bill because um a lot of
our constituents are been seeing some
additional fees when they are requesting
a um paper
billing but followup please yes for the
question in is that also true um when
they send mailin payments they're being
charged for those in other words if I
send a a a payment of $50 in that is
that I'm Drew am I going to be charged
should Fe on top of
that I don't think I understand the
question right but if you are asking for
a paper Bill to send out to you and
that's basically they are charging you
for
it follow I'm just looking at the
analysis that says for paying by mail
and I I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't
read the analysis but but you're
concerned that you're in in the actual
language of the bill that there's a fee
being charged for paying uh through
through mailing it back rather than okay
so we you know let's we'll dig into that
but I would not wa you know lay on the
analysis you know analysis can be
confusing sometimes so that is in the
bill though so it is in the bill okay
we're electing to make a payment by
United States mail or electing to
make so so they back dilling you for
that I don't know that a good question I
don't know okay uh are you all set any
more questions I do have one other
question um do you see any problem with
the enforcement Clause that is included
here uh given that the Department of
Justice will be responsible for this and
there are some heavy duty fines that are
levied
here I don't see any problem with that
um I have um spoken with a lawyer and
about this to make sure that um
businesses are not taking advantage of
it so making sure that it's been heavily
um put the fine in there so that way if
a cons consumer opts in for a paper and
so that way they cannot charge it and
for that matter we are trying to protect
our uh you um citizens of New Hampshire
who is desperate for their paper
Billings rather than um letting them to
um be fined I mean uh been charged for a
fee so having this heavy um fee I think
would be uh beneficial to kind of
convince the businesses to let the uh
choice for the consumers thank you very
much yeah so I would interject before I
take more questions just to make sure
everybody understands this is um under
3505 uh9 uh which is uh follow under the
consumer protection statutes um and uh
so just so everybody knows um
technically technically um in actuality
uh any financial institutions Banks um
Securities uh insurance and um uh public
utility commissions are Exempted from
this statute so if it's a utility or if
it's a bank that's charging for the
statement they would be exempt from this
legislation okay so next up is
Anita Bros represent Bros yes thanks for
uh thank you representative for taking
my question it's just a quick one um I'm
just curious why is the term person use
in the bill rather than corporate entity
and because it's saying that persons
will be Char you know will be fine so
you know why is it not a corporate
entity because individuals penalties
they'll have both they'll say person and
then they'll
say uh a person
fine yeah um I guess under 358 then then
terms of if there's somewhere else where
it talks about a person being a business
then it's um that's correct Mr chairman
I can tell you that in under um yeah
statutory construction
lawed as a corporation as well as an
individual Thank you Pam this is great
having you here right behind
me okay uh and any other questions you
also said Nita okay uh representative
aberson is
next uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Wy for taking my um
question I'm noticing that you've
Exempted um state agencies from
this yes I have exam Ed state agencies
due to um to be honest with you um um I
think we the state itself needs the
revenues and um according to what I
heard from the last um year testimony
that they bring forth um about 7
$775,000 I believe in revenues according
to that so um I think the state of New
Hampshire needs the revenue so I make
sure that we exempt
that so um
question you may inquire I'm sorry
follow say can I have a yeah yeah go go
ahead so I it just seems like it's a the
uh the state applying rules to certain
types of businesses and then exempting
itself and for pretty hefty fines $500
on the first offense which is um pretty
significant for a small business or a
startup and then 5,000 for a second
offense I think we'd see a lot more of
the $500 First Defense um penalties
that's quite a bit of money um and then
on top of that somebody's going to be
asking me the question when they get hit
with this um Can the state uh charge you
an extra fee for trying to pay that $500
fine by
mail I mean first of all if if this bill
passes through uh and becomes a law and
um those businesses should be
considering in following the law so if
they really want to pay that $500 then
they can charge the consumer and you
know uh take it take it up to the court
so um it's better off for them not to
charge that $2 fee and not get fined so
that is the exception of this to um
follow the rule or not to follow the
rule okay you the question Max yeah
follow up is is there um there are all
sorts of different types of
businesses um every time we come up with
a fee or a fine or regulation there's
always some new startup that hits all
the Reg regulations that we come up with
for existing established businesses that
we know of um and you may have a
business that provides some type of
Internet service or Internet billing
service and for them the cost of
processing
paper um you know paper bills like these
oops like we don't we don't you're not
supposed to show things
oh um their cost of process
uh by paper could be as much as $20 per
um bill um so they may um set up
something that's done exclusively
through online billing but then if they
want to make a slight change um and
except for an exceptional circumstance
um their their processing cost could be
very high are they supposed to just eat
the processing cost
themselves thanks for that question um
um representative evson as you can see
this this is not new okay so um
companies has done providing mailin
bills previously and as we are just
moving with technology it's become a of
of a new thing for uh online billing or
online payment so um like I said earlier
on my testimony that very little
majority of our uh New Hampshire
citizens could pop poed into this so
there won't be too much of a a big
burden for the businesses it's just
allowing an option for our individuals
to opt in or to stay in as of um you
know opt in for the paper or pay online
so just giving that option for
individuals would be good um just like
our state moto Live Free or
Die okay uh representative ham has a
question yes thank you uh Mr chairman um
I I too was wondering um part two
nothing uh in this applies to
governmental agencies along the same
lines um does that include all
governmental agencies towns and and you
know there there are many types of
governmental agencies and many types of
consumers or folks that are paying bills
and their ability to do so on the
internet so I was just wondering if this
applies to all of them including
municipalities yes all the um um New
Hampshire um businesses that are
entitled to the
state okay and representative
Terry uh thank you Mr chairman uh
representative wasir and um colleagues
on the committee I want to make clear
that I'm in an investigatory or inquiry
mode here so my question should not be
taken as indicating any position at this
point on your proposed legislation I'll
be the judge of that excuse me I said I
will be the judge of of your question
because I might say to you would you
believe if I decide that your question
was not a question go
ahead uh clearly and indisputably I
think we're we can consider the charges
that are levied to pay uh to receive a
paper Bill uh to be a kind of user
fee um if in fact we prohibit any
charges for levying such a user fee then
somebody's going to have to
pay and the people who are going to have
to pay are the people who are paying uh
electronically it have you given any
consideration to um how those who opt to
pay
electronically would be
protected if your
legislation is to was to pass protected
in the sense that they would not end up
having to pay for the people who are
choosing to uh continue to pay um via
the traditional old method of paper
billing is that a question Mr chairman
that's a question thank
you well thank you uh representative
Terry that is a similar question to the
previous um answer that I I gave um but
it's obviously the businesses already
have done providing paper billing
previous years um before like five years
ago seven years ago before we came into
this
technology um no you will not be charged
extra for those who are opt in you know
opt in for um online banking you will
pay your your share and um it will be it
will be a a great um thing for the
business to provide for those who are
wants to be opting for
paper so it will not make any um it will
not make additional fees for your um
your perspective if you I think what
he's pling is is that that that that if
a business would intend that there's a
certain amount of percentage of people
who will pay the fee and if all of a
sudden they're not getting that fee
anymore then they're going to pass on
that cost whatever Revenue they thought
they were going to get that they're
going to pass that cost uh it's going to
offset some costs they're going to pass
that cost on to everybody so therefore
the rest of us who really are still
paying electronically are subsidizing
this benefit for those who can't afford
it well I don't have an answer to that
Mr chair but um it does come up a
question for me if if the businesses
were able to provide hard cop Cy of a
statement or billing previous years many
years ago um how they were covering
their charges you know how they were
coming out with those uh extra charges
that they are now putting on our
consumers so I would like to know that
answer what if a businesses well I can
venture to give you an answer to that
one just like in the old days Airlines
never charge for luggage and now they do
and what's happened is is that they
lowered their ticket
prices but then added fees so I think
what representative Terry is going with
this is the exact same thing that if you
are removing the fee collection
therefore there will have to raise their
prices for whatever product they're
selling to offset that lost
Revenue well I don't have that answer to
that Mr chair representative Terry was I
was I on the Mark or not well well Mr
chairman I was actually gonna follow up
with uh questions that would have St
been stated uh in a very similar manner
but I would like to uh thank you for
what did not anticipate to be a tag team
on this question and uh thank you for um
saying what I didn't have to say you're
asking what I didn't have to ask thank
you very much you read my mind okay
perfect okay representative Abel is
next thank you representative for uh
your testimony I want to make sure that
I'm clear on on one issue I believe uh
uh that this bill while it would
prohibit additional fees for for someone
who transacts business by paper or mail
um would not prohibit a business from
offering a
discount uh or rebate for uh for
electing to uh to make an electronic
trans that correct doesn't it it the
business still has the right to give an
incentive to someone who goes electronic
and
discounts correct you are correct thank
you and Mr chair I'll end my questions
from here uh I would like to leave to
other members if you would like to
testify okay fair enough thank you so uh
I would ask uh for those people who
raised their hands to put them down and
uh so next up is Walter
Stapleton uh is that is he a rep no uh
see I guess yes he is he's okay it
doesn't say it just says myself okay uh
so Walter I am now you're uh I am now
GNA promote you
and as a
panelist and go ahead
Welter
and was I'm going to just demote you
hope hope you don't
mind
and are you up
Bal yes he's here
okay uh make
sure thank you uh Mr chair and um
members of the committee um Walt
Stapleton um Claremont War three
representative Sullivan County District
5 and I'm also a co-sponsor um to uh
this bill HB 76
FN
um I I believe that uh the invoicing is
an expected usual and basic
responsibility of a business relating
their charges for services and goods to
their
customers and as a matter of customer
service should be done in the medium and
the usually expected ways that uh we're
C accustomed to receiving now we are on
the threshold
of electronics or internet but there are
many people out there that do not have
that
capability um or it's intermittent in
its
Effectiveness um and many people while
they do have the cap ability and are
involved with computers um in my
experience they're they're not often
looking at their obligations or their
emails I've got a case where in in other
venues and
organizations I'm almost at the point of
um de disusing emails because nobody's
reading them um and and that's a problem
because people miss things and they
could be missing their their billing
uh if they don't go on to the vendor's
website or um look at the vendor's email
that contains an invoice so I think it's
an unfair thing to expect um ubiquitous
observation of emails and
websites
um we're seeing the the effect of more
and more companies and financial
institution Banks uh wanting to convert
to Green paperless and that's a good
thing but that has to be for those
people who want that and are capable of
doing it that should not be forced upon
uh the general consumer um and
especially not those people who don't
have the capability or or don't have the
management capability to uh to Monitor
and keep up with uh all the many bills
that could come electronically and then
of course when the electronic means fail
for hurricanes or storms or
[Music]
out so there's also that Spectre of fees
late fees for missing or late turn in of
uh of the payment on these bills so I'm
I'm in support of this and and this is
like a preemptive defense against um a
movement towards uh removing paper from
um from the culture and the Commerce
that and I think we do need to have the
paper um and for those that that can't
use or don't want to use the other
capability that we're developing
electronically and I guess that
summarizes um my feeling of support uh
for hb76 FN thank you all right thank
you uh do we have questions yeah
representative gson you have a
question yeah I I I thank you Mr
chairman and maybe uh because you
addressed this a little bit earlier um
when you said that according to statute
there are actually some uh entities that
would be exempt from this legislation
anyway uh am I understanding this
correctly that uh Banks would be exempt
uh the utilities would be exempt from
this we we already I'm I'm I know that
the state would be exempt and I
understanding that uh towns and counties
would be exempt so who exactly would
this apply to I I Bob's Garage
what thank you anticipating that a large
number of people um and who who use uh
anything from
uh from the local garage or or uh
vendors or
contractors uh that come into the home
um there's a whole array of businesses
out there um that that you could lump
into that'll still use the paper billing
with a good and a good effect uh in
relating to their customers for the
charges for the the services and the
goods that they they provide um I I
would prefer that uh those exempt
organizations would also respect um
people's inability to um deal with the
internet and continue a paper billing on
a courtesy if not on on an obligatory uh
fashion um I think that's just good
customer service good business to uh Aid
your customers and pay in their
bills Mr chairman can I follow this up
just sir you can do a followup question
yes thank you sir I appreciate it and
thank you uh representative stapon uh so
how could I mean just thinking putting
on my devil's advocate cap here um how
could I at Bob's G garage uh just not
send out a paper statement then just
have sort of like all these companies
have shipping and handling charges uh
shipping is the cost of actually sending
the product and the handling is some
mysterious charge the cardboard box the
envelope the stamp all that other sort
of stuff so how do I not just put
shipping and handling uh or something
along those Natures in my bill uh and
send it to you and it's basically
getting around this legislation it's not
a fee for doing paper billing it's my
shipping and handling
fee yeah um we I don't don't
misunderstand this is Devil's Advocate
I'm not advocating skirting the
law you as the question okay that's good
yeah I think that's that's a great
question and I think it's already
happening um you know you buy an item
and it's discounted and it's the best on
Amazon or the internet for uh $9.95
everybody else is $15 and then you get
to the checkout and then the uh the
shipping and handling is1
15.95 and then you got to cancel that
and go back and find out who's got the
free shipping uh so that you can get the
real price the real Allin price um and
you know when when I'm faced with that
I'm looking at that vendor and I'm
saying okay they're going to play this
uh uh this shell game trick here's one
price but when you get to the check out
here's another which one which shell is
the pee underneath of and then I'm going
to decline to go to that vendor uh ever
again because I know the tricks that
they're going to play um and I've been
in business myself and fair billing
clear billing paper billing is what I
always used and uh be prepared to defend
your bill and be fair with all of the
peripheral charges and the assessments
that you make on that bill that bill is
a testimony of how well you do business
and how well you attitude of customer
service is and it goes hand inand with
the uh estimate which is also generally
a paper thing but can be
electronic um sometimes I think in the
society we don't give enough attention
to the clerical aspects of running a
business and making it clear and helpful
for people to be able to read understand
follow and pay their
invoices great uh repr restive aberson
has is next in line for a
question okay so this this rule applies
this isn't a consumer protection for New
Hampshire consumers this is a
restriction on businesses or a fine for
businesses that make the mistake of
moving to New Hampshire um because
they're the ones that that would be hit
by this but I'm I'm still looking at
this and I'm thinking okay if you have a
business that is trying to offer some
kind of discount for people who do the
electronic
payment they want to pass that on that
looks like it's still a price
differential how do you guarantee that
you can avoid the fine or somebody going
to be caught unawares not realizing that
that uh they're going to be hit with
this this fine for uh offering a
discount yeah I I don't see in the bill
any uh against that mention of it and
and I think once again it goes to fair
business practice um you
already rep Stapleton C could you uh
make sure you're not rubbing your phone
against your facial hair or your shirt
or something like
that I get the paper in front of me
sorry about that yeah okay um we we
already do that when we give discounts
uh for senior citizens um Andor volume
discounts uh why can't we give one for
um electronic use to save that customer
that's the incentive for the customer to
compromise away from the paper billing I
think that's in line with what we're
already doing and I don't think the bill
prohibits that or affects it followup um
okay yes sir further question right all
right further question it is the bill
just says no person shall charge a
consumer an additional rate or fee for
electing to make a payment by United
States mail or receiving paper billing
statement that that means any
differential between electronic and
paying by paper so they they're not if
there's a discount offered to pay
electronically then there effectively is
a different rate charge and this is what
this is saying an additional rate or fee
additional rate or fee so it's it's two
different rates so how do you guarantee
that uh you don't get caught by this um
you know and get hit with the f
well I I would say that um the
difference is if you're going to charge
a fee for a paper billing that's an
upfront
charge um and if you're not going to
charge the fee but you may give a
discount for an electronic billing that
that would be a backend charger discount
what the bill is trying to do is prevent
a wholesale sweep into a movement where
you're going to eliminate the paper
billing and affect those
people again yeah
okay I thought it was static on the
phone line but I don't know what you're
doing with your hands or um I'm
basically still but
um phone
interference some kind of interference
yeah
some okay um all right so I think we'll
move on um max so uh representative
Terry thank you Mr chairman
representative Stapleton um I'm in
sympathy
with uh the thrust of the
bill and the central feature of as I
understand it of not uh levying
additional charges on people who who opt
to uh to receive a paper Bill and go
that route however I am deeply troubled
by the
exemptions um and I I need to really
hear what the rationale is for each of
the exempts in this legisl proposed
legislation um first we're in a we're
living in a time where there's there's
deep cynicism developing uh towards uh
double
standards and um when we read that the
government um and utilities for example
example are granted exemptions people
are going to react many people are going
to react in in the way uh that this once
again these are rules for for me but not
for thee and so I'm I I really need
before I can can move forward and and
feel positively about this bill uh I I
need to know what the rationale is for
all of these exemptions it's deeply
troubling
um uh I would have
preferred the bill without exemptions
but I'm not the sponsor I'm the I'm a
co-sponsor and that question should
really be answered by the sponsor who's
worked uh long and hard on bringing this
bill to you um because I I do feel that
there should be uh some further
protection even for those that are
listed as
Exempted but I'm supporting this bill
because I like the direction that it's
moving in away from what the culture is
tending to do um by uh discouraging
paper um billing and paper payment uh
and I think we have to put the breaks on
that so in my view I'm supporting this
bill because it's a start in the general
in the right direction uh to protect the
consumer at the lower end um who can't
use or doesn't want to use uh electronic
means for
payment great thank you very much for
your
testimony uh the chair will now call on
Diane shuid who I am now moving you up
to a panelist
Diane
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee um my name is Diane Shu uh I
represent marac 20 the towns of
Chichester and Pembrook I'm also a co-pa
on this bill and uh I did submit written
testimony but uh a lot of it repeats
what's already been stated um my main
thrust with this is protection for
seniors who tend to not own computers
not do business online and depend on
paper billing to keep track of things uh
I will tell you that uh number one I'm a
senior citizen myself but I also help um
several senior couples in my community
uh drive them to do shopping uh so forth
and for them a lot of their issues are
keeping track of things we all know that
it's less expensive for all of us the
state and our communities to keep
seniors living in their homes as long as
possible and one of the major reasons
that they have to abandon living at home
and move into nursing homes or whatever
is their inability to take care of their
own financial matters uh I would say in
answer to one of the questions I heard
previously um about paying utilities and
so forth being Exempted I think probably
these seniors tend to keep track of
those better because it's something that
occurs monthly whereas getting the car
fixed and paying Bob's Garage is a
random case and to be honest I have one
couple particularly who constantly have
the the discussion did we pay so and so
well if they've gotten a paper Bill and
they've kept their portion of that paper
bill which is usually the case they can
look back and see yes oh yeah there it
is I sent the portion with the payment
right it's a way for them to
maintain their financial Independence
and stay in their homes uh I would also
point out uh one of the questions put
forward was uh paying fees for internet
billing and I would submit that most of
the people that this bill applies to uh
would not be charging things over the
internet if they don't have a computer
to pay their bill they're probably not
buying goods or services over the
internet as well so it's another case
that they're not going to be applying
this
fee and I would also say that if you do
opt to pay your bills by internet the
fees that are charged are inherent when
you start that process most companies
that charge fees for Internet service
that's implied right right from the
get-go when you take that option uh and
I think we all have to be aware that
fees such as the chairman mentioned uh
for baggage and so forth are subject to
change um so that's about all that I
have to add if there are further
questions I'd be glad to
answer uh representative van hton has a
question thank you I think I have more
of a would you believe kind of question
but I would just like to throw this out
um the vaccination the covid vaccination
roll out featured many elderly people
who only had access to to making their
registration by means of phone and would
you say that they were although this
isn't quite the same as paper building I
see it as a parallel would you say that
that's a case in point to support the
need for taking care of these elderly
senior citizens uh definitely one of
them uh I will say um for those of you
who aren't aware um a seniors were uh
given the option seniors and folks that
can't afford computers to call two 11 uh
over the telephone which almost every
senior at least have access to
telephones uh I will point out I tried
to help one of my my seniors that I
assist and it took us uh a half an hour
of calling 211 to get through it was
constantly busy but that was an option
rather than uh making your appointment
online
yourself so yeah that
definitely um the the part of our
population that this bill is aiming to
help uh I will say also the the thought
occurred to me when um I think it was
representative Terry was talking about
um exempting utilities and so forth the
only entity that this bill specifically
exempts is government entities those
other um billing entities utilities and
so forth as the chairman mentioned
that's already in the law we aren't
putting that in this that was already
there so you're gonna have to ask the
sponsor of that section of the RSA what
they were thinking when they had made
those
exemptions fair enough uh
and uh so representative Abramson has a
question we're we're running up a time
here Max
okay it's quickest question ever so the
bill and and these laws in general don't
apply to New Hampshire oops my hair's
out of place don't apply to New
Hampshire consumers they apply to those
businesses that move to New Hampshire so
if you have a new startup or or this
this isn't a startup at all uh if Unitil
wanted to move their operations from
Boston to New Hampshire they could no
longer that's not a good example they're
they're a public utility so there would
be well if a company wanted to move from
B sorry Mr chair if if company wanted to
move from Boston to New Hampshire they
would be facing this penalty and the
legal question of whether or not they
could charge a different rate for paper
versus uh online billing is that
correct theoretically they should
hopefully they know our laws before they
make the decision to move to the state
of Hamshire well I don't know the law
but I'm not sure that you know at this
point it's not a law at this moment so
let's you know I don't know what the
bill would mean even looking at it
whether or not they would be penalized
for offering the discount I hear you I
hear your question I understand where
you're coming from um thank you Mr chair
that's exactly the point I would have
made also that they know what they're
facing when they decide to come here
okay fair enough thank you very much
okay uh Suzanne Vale and I have already
upgraded you Suzanne so you can go ahead
and
testify Mr chair um thank you Mr
chairman and honorable colleagues um and
thank you for taking my testimony in
support of
HB 76 I am representative Suzanne Vale
of Nash ward 3 and I'm representing both
my district and myself which is
Hillsboro 30 and I'm also a co-sponsor
of the
bill I have personally experienced
difficulty with navigating onlight
statement and payment the whole
Revolution really here is a small
example out of many that I've had um I
had a problem with my cell phone service
this year I bought a hot spot equipment
in order for my daughter to travel on
serious family business but she wasn't
getting the amount of data that we paid
for and
um I logged into our account and I could
see that in fact the device was now on a
different plan I searched for the
transactions that would have caused this
I opened a chat and was told that the
online view I was looking at is not kept
current for transactions like the one I
would be looking for and that they would
not necessarily be reflected in the bill
that I would be able to see online
whether that was true or not the answer
was not online I would never have been
able to resolve this if I weren't
grudgingly willing to pay their $2 fee
to get the
bills I was able able to track the
transaction once I got the information
and I found the date and the time of
mistake so then I was able to call and
ask them to fix what I had found I can't
personally attest that my information
was not on their website but I couldn't
find it and the only way I could fix
this is with to get the paperwork and
turn the computer off and sit down and
reconcile it these fees seem to be
levied by companies that really have you
over a barrel we had a serious family
emergency going on and we needed that
hotspot to be delivering the service
that we paid for I will be staying with
the paper bills just as a matter of
trust on the basis of that incident
although I've had many but I really
believe that getting in on the paper
with that company will give me great
efficacy in the problem solving in other
words I can keep my computer shut and I
don't have to worry about it now no one
has a $2 a month fee to spare in order
to trust their vendor but I am very
fortunate now as as a state
representative and just as a person in
my life I have a lot of support there
are a lot of people that have broad man
that could help me where I unable to
access it um I have other courses to
take in terms of getting help from other
people but calls emails and chats that
solve nothing are far more serious is a
problem to people who don't have
internet or the resources every day it
gets harder for the elderly and
disadvantaged people to make it living
alone we can't allow companies to take
away the $2 from our residents in order
to encourage more streamlined online
bill paying and autod dting society that
we now live in it's wonderful to see all
these amazing technological advances I'm
kind of a geek and I love it myself but
as my 81 yearold stepdad astutely says
knowledge has a halflife of five years
nowadays and I think it's true what
started as a way to encourage folks to
pay online is now a way to keep
consumers from their own information and
the way that they can access it time has
passed since people would pick up the
phone when you have a problem and answer
it without asking you to wait online for
a year the original plan that has been
executed I feel is no longer ethical 10
years ago when they wanted to encourage
people to pay bills online and receive
these things and you know they it's all
very good but um that 10 years has gone
by large companies do this I support the
fines on the basis of their ability to
afford to pay them I know that telom
companies can afford this and they can
process to they can afford to process
any kind of payment I I I believe that I
have looked around me wherever I go
which isn't far these days and I see
elderly people ask for their phone
number their rewards number everything
under the sun in order to make a cash
transaction in a Walgreens we can't be
so indifferent when we're trying to
insist people who do not have access or
the ability to comprehend the constant
change in the way that money transacts
today in the changing world it is my
hope that the committee will support the
bill and if they find necessary to make
the necessary amendments that address
the questions that arose today um if
there's an issue with the smaller
companies being affected you could
exempt companies with a small amount of
employees in any fashion that you you
know is legal I am not an expert I thank
you so much for hearing my anecdotal te
testimony and with that I will take
questions um the committee members may
have okay I don't see any hands up um so
I think you're oh uh representative mle
has a
question what if a company opted out of
M uh mail billing alog together and they
said they would only bill um online how
would they how would this Bill affect
them I don't think I can answer that
question but as I was looking looking um
into the bill originally when it was
filed the first time um I found that I
think it's against federal law so I
don't want to say for sure but I think
there's some federal um legislation that
prevents people from not giving a
statement of any kind on
paper yeah I don't know anything about
that but I I would say that in your
example um of using a cell phone company
cell phone companies are not regulated
by the Pu so they would not be exempt
from the statute and the assumption
would be is uh the reason that is true
is that there is a free market that you
can choose and shop around when it comes
to cell phone companies and so therefore
there was no need for the public
utilities to be involved in regulating
that industry so uh seeing no more
question oh uh representative aberson
we're we're out of time Max so make it
quick okay as quick as I can so you say
had two companies this doesn't apply to
New Hampshire consumers it applies to
New Hampshire businesses that do
business in New Hampshire correct so if
we have a if you have a New Hampshire
billing company and they're competing
with somebody in Massachusetts is this
now putting the New Hampshire company at
a competitive
disadvantage not in my
opinion not in my opinion um I come from
a land where if you pay cash you get a
discount that's the way it is at my
printer and and you all know how much
the house depends on printed material so
what I can say about interstate commerce
is that I know when the laws get
stricter in California they seem to get
stricter everywhere and that's suppos to
be a joke
so well we don't want to throw other
states under the
bus all right well thank you very much
uh and I uh we see let's see I got a
bunch of people who did not testify but
would like to uh weigh in here on the
blue sheet uh Rebecca M Williams
represented Williams uh is in support of
the bill uh and we have Nicole
40 uh she's a member of the public and
she is in support of the bill I have a
Jared Cape who is uh all I know is he's
got a Dartmouth um email address and he
is opposed to the bill I have Lucy
Coello um who is a member of the public
and supports the bill and I have a Eric
Rathbun uh who is a member of the public
and is opposed to the bill uh I have
Josh yoka who is an elected official so
he's a state repap Josh and he is
opposed to the bill um I have
represented Mary Beth walls and she is
in support of the bill and we have
representa Linda gold who is also in
support of the bill Tom Dolan
representative Dolan and supported the
bill uh and then we have Alvin C who's a
member of the public who's opposed to
the bill and we have Ryan hail of the
New Hampshire Bankers Association uh who
is opposed to the bill and with that
we'll close the public hearing on House
Bill
76 and as I said before this bill 76 is
an early Bill along with the first one
we heard 610 so we will try I will try
to uh
schedule exec sessions fairly quickly I
think it's going to be let's say the
third day that we meet is when I have a
schedule in for their exec
sessions uh given the time is 10:56 so
we'll now move on to our last bill for
this
morning and uh that is uh House Bill
475 so I would ask uh the sponsor to
wave put raise your hand so you would
pop to the top of my
list and and there's
Jordan and okay Jordan I am going to
promote you to a panel oh oh J moves
around on me jump around promote you to
a panelist and uh repres Yori you're
recognized to introduce the
bill as soon as I finally un mute button
here you go very good thank you my name
is Jordan erery Hillsboro 37 this bill
was introduced because of several
consumer complaints that have been
received regarding um individuals uh
businesses entities copying their
driver's license and then the uh
constituent began receiving all sorts of
unsolicited advertising materials uh
affiliated with that particular entity
it actually happened uh with me when I
got a new transmission put in my truck
uh over at
um Buick in uh Nashville they
photocopied the driver's license and I
said well RSA 2614 says you can't do
that and they said whether do you want
your transmission or
not
um that's a problem you'll notice I sent
out to you a proposed amendment to this
to address some of the concerns of the
pharmaceutical
entities um by Mr Stout I would like for
you to consider that if at all possible
and as language it uh it makes sense the
key uh section of this is down in on
line nine paragraph C which says that if
they're going to uh look at your license
then they have to provide you with a
coper copy of the uh driver privacy
protection policy of the business now
that business is required under federal
law under the it's the dppa the you know
how you love acronyms the driver Federal
driver privacy protection act which
means that any entity using a driver's
license has to have a policy in effect
protecting the privacy of the driver
license information that has a your
driver's license has a lot of
information on it your name your address
under the uh uh fair credit protection
act and the uh fair debt collection
protection act that information is
considered private personal information
and is protected by federal law
you not you're supposed to keep
it secure from any outside entity and
just like when you sign up online for
something they have to disclose that
they're going to be using it for that
purpose currently in New Hampshire that
doesn't happen uh in the particular
instance involves the largest
pharmaceutical Pharmacy uh business in
the United States CVS uh went over and
apparently Nashville maintains a large
supply of drugs uh OPI opioid drugs that
they don't have when they're smaller
areas so you they're forcing people to
go to one location which is a good idea
they demand the identity of the person
picking up the LI uh the uh drugs that's
perfectly fine there's no problem with
that but then they take the um driver's
license and copy it or and like one
person said they they scanned it in
which again is a violation of New
Hampshire state
law so
apparently when confronted on this they
they said that the Nashville police
instructed them that they had to do it
well if the Nashville police are saying
that they have to violate
2614 then the Nashville police need to
have a lesson in Consumer Protection Law
and the driver privacy protection act
which probably is a good idea anyway but
uh for all the police departments not
just
Nashville the situation is that there
needs some more clarification some more
strengthening of this you will also see
in your inboxes a letter from um former
representative Neil Kirk who was he and
I didn't see eye to eye on a lot of
things as uh your chair knows but uh
he's also in favor of this bill uh with
the perhaps the uh addition of the
amendment suggest by the uh uh
pharmacies uh with that I will take any
questions and uh be glad to answer
them okay uh I don't see any hands up
yet but uh representa make sure I
understand what you said was that the
anybody could use the license but they
have to have a written policy or they
have to have a a policy of ensuring the
privacy of that driver's license
information that's correct that's what
I'm going to say right well cuz that
that's a kind of a few for me because um
uh as some people might know I rent I
rent my castle here and uh when I rent
it not standing that some people can
book directly through uh vbo but when
people direct book with me directly I
actually asked for their credit for
their driver's license and um and some
of them send me very nice I got a 3x5
nice picture card of some of's driver's
license and the purpose of of I doing it
is that a is that I'm I'm people come in
you know live in my house uh so I like
to H match up make sure that when they
send me their contract and and and the
check that they pay me with which can
sometimes be sketchy is I want like to
have the driver's license match up with
that but more importantly is that we
have an age requirement you know they
have to be 30 so I like to make sure
that they just because they said they're
30 that I actually have documentation of
it so as long as I have we have a policy
about how we protect the privacy of that
driver's license um so um I'm not
breaking the law hopefully yeah so long
as you have a policy that's what it says
in paragraph C line
uh okay well I don't need it I don't
need it just need to be sure okay uh
representative abson has his hand
up sorry actually that was kind of my
question you're just saying that you
just want them to have a policy so if
they take your driver's license and
photocopy it and uh keep a copy of it
for some amount of time wouldn't it make
make more sense to limit the amount of
time that they could keep it say 90 days
or 30 days or something and then destroy
the paper so that uh you don't have that
material uh lying around I um am not
objecting to that at all I am objecting
to them scanning the driver's license
because there's some information on the
M magnetic strip that is law enforcement
oriented excuse me when I
cough
um some of the information on the
magnetic strip is uh is
proprietary and there's when if it's
scanned in then they have to go back in
and scan it but I have no uh objection
to adding to that the key thing is that
businesses and law enforcement need to
understand that there is a uh existing
law RSA 2614 and this in consumer
protection would then also enhance that
by saying you have to protect this
information if you want to be in
business and if you want to demand that
information it's it's as simple as that
um and uh to answer your Chairman's uh
comment about uh having a policy it just
you can just say my policy is that I
follow the Federal dppa which means you
don't share it with anyone unless you're
giving unless there's a positive uh
consent to share that
information um but yeah I can see
maintaining a a time limit thank you Max
okay okay follow-up question sure uh all
right so this only applies to
reproduction or copying this wouldn't
apply to you know just somebody looking
at the driver's license it's only if
it's if they're making a copy you want
them to have a policy correct if they
make a copy or maintain the information
going up to h a pharmacy and and saying
I'm picking up some hydrocodone because
uh I broke my uh ribs and I did earlier
last year late in the fall um and
showing your license to show that you
are who the person on the prescription
is that that's common sense but making a
copy of it and then perhaps giving that
copy to the police department later of
all the people that uh got
hydrocodone and that's that's that's a
little bit too
far okay thank you representative
burough yes um thank you for taking my
question representative just a quick
question um do you know how extensive a
problem there is other than the
anecdotal um you know evidence that you
had um with the
transmission
well I've had several people contact me
on that most of them have been dealing
with the drug companies in nashv or the
pharmacies in Nashville uh we don't
really have any drug companies but the
phes in Nashville and of course I'm in
in this area I've also and some of my
fraternal activities had uh coffee
discussions with individuals where this
has become common practice for them to
um make a copy of your driver's license
for if you're paying by check and
yet one of Mr Kirks or former
representative
Kirk's primary things was to prevent the
placing of the driver's license number
on a commercial paper that is spread out
everywhere
so they're they're circumventing the
intent of existing law so I think this
just tightens it up a little bit and
clarifies it but at the same time
doesn't place an excessive burden on the
businesses and I'm open to suggestions
for uh making a more better uh
wording okay um see no other hands
up uh oh yeah okay see I got this
problem with the committee room yeah see
yes your binoculars out yeah
representative Johnson uh please thank
you have just speak loud now
too
does oh you're bleeping out now the
microphone's not even picking you
up are you can't hear me this doesn't
work yeah do you mind walking I don't
know maybe the micro can you see where
the microphone
is is this better yes there you go so my
question how does
this oh you did you're dying out again
you were there and then all of a sudden
I don't know is that you Aon in the room
yeah okay there's Aaron okay thank
you how does this affect going into and
registering to vote and showing ID
because you need that you need your ID
they need that paperwork and they need
to see so how does that affect that it
doesn't affect at all because you're
merely showing your driver's license
they're not copying the
information and and uh okay yep okay uh
all right any other questions from the
committee members and did anybody else I
uh did any else was going to testify
Jordan or is it was just you right U
there I there are two emails that should
be in the uh committee uh yeah we do
have some files yep we got that okay all
right so then um now we just uh to uh by
reading the the blue sheet assuming that
was that that's it for questions um
let's see Marty Moy from the insurance
department which uh is new neutral but
they would technically be exempt uh Eric
uh rman uh member of the public and
supports the bill uh representative Tom
floa
floa okay and he also supports the bill
uh Curtis Barry a lobbyist for the New
Hampshire retail association is opposed
to the bill uh Dan Bennett from the Auto
Dealers Association is also opposed to
the
bill uh and we just heard from Jordan uh
represented Linda Gould um and she's uh
she is on support of the bill and
finally Paul
Sanderson uh from the New Hampshire
fishing game department is opposed to
the bill um and with that um we will
close the public hearing on um House
Bill
475 all right well amazing how that one
didn't take as long as I thought it
would take okay so uh at this point uh
we are uh in going to go in recess until
uh at 1:15 excuse me Mr chairman there's
one more morning Bill there's Bill Oh I
thought I had House Bill
109 representative aler bill so how do I
oh okay that was good planning oh some
reason I thought it was after lunch okay
uh so that's at uh
10:45 so we're we're past that moment so
we can uh
11:15 oh where am I five
minutes almost perfect okay so everybody
can take a break for five minutes sorry
about that I this somehow I thought that
was
115 not looking at my paper correctly
John can I ask you a question yes go
ahead how can an agency be anything but
neutral oh they
are well
uh I I I I I'm my guess
they uh it's an
agency um not withstanding the insurance
department which is exemp but they I
don't know they they
um I don't know why she felt compelled
to do that we'll have next time I see
Marty I'll ask her yeah that's I it's
the same question I ask in ways and
means when one of the agencies come in
uh your job is type thing yeah well we
certainly for instance we have the
agency bills and they're certainly in
support of their own bills they can't be
neutral on their own
bills it's just a pet peeve I I would
prefer them to come in and say this
would have the effect of and why they're
either yeah I I like I say I'll have to
ask her why she why she did that but
maybe I don't know I think she might
have put herself on the list just so in
case somebody had a question about
insurance or something maybe but so
yeah no problem okay so Erin I do see
you and Mr Speaker how are you uh um I
the question I have is I can't see if if
the two members in the committee rooms
don't have computers I don't know I
can't really see
them um if they want a question because
it's so puny even though I've got it on
full screen here I I can barely barely
see so if you speak you'll you could
jump up to the front of my screen I
assume
right I can't even hear anything are you
guys is
it it's not muted in the committee room
yeah I see it's not muted but the
microphone are you I see Aaron
disappearing so maybe Aaron's working on
the microphone he's near the Monitor and
the computer up in front and the big
speaker is but I don't know what he's
doing I get yeah
hi
eron you look like one of what is those
cartoon characters that that uh talk
about scary movies that the editor they
pop up at the bottom of the
screen and Mr chairman I do see that jod
grimus has her hand up I don't know over
an attendees over an attendees I don't
know what um she may want to say but
okay uh let me click on her yes Jody did
you have did you want to testify on that
bill or did did
you you can you can unmute there you go
I did I had signed up through the
testimony system I don't know if that
showed up but unfortunately when what
time did you do that I did it this
morning when I learned about the
bill and I printed them out you know at
uh 30 minutes before the the hearing or
maybe 15
minutes for the first hearing right I
you and I had said to you Pam that and
I'm sorry about this J because I was
going to say to people that if you want
to speak make sure you raise your hand
but I I just I just didn't see it I'm
sorry when did you raise your hand did
you raise your hand before we closed the
hearing I did because I I you had said
that there was nobody else left to speak
so I raised it but again you may not
have seen it if I was on the yeah what
what I was looking at but again yeah huh
sorry about that um but you can
certainly submit written testimony for
the committee I will do that and I will
check into the CVS issue that was um
mentioned in nashwa because that's that
was new to us okay oh that's one of your
clients okay great all right appreciate
it could I get copi down there John
please um I will certainly uh when I get
her testimony I will forward it to you
yes I will send it to as well represent
that would be great thank you Jody y I
will thank you Jody
okay now you can lower your
hand I can do it for you right I
can uh lower hand there we go I lowered
your hand oh talking still
permitted disa talking I'm gonna disable
you sorry
okay well that went
okay so far so good all right so it's
11:15 um and do I still have my
clerk Keith are you still there yep all
right so uh we'll open up the public
hearing on uh our uh 11 House
Bill uh 11 109 and here from the primary
sponsor representative yri good morning
representative yri uh good morning Mr
chairman and I haven't seen you in at
least 30 minutes
um um for the record my name is Jordan
oler representing Hillsboro 37 Hudson
and pelum down the southern part of the
State uh the this Bill had been
introduced last year and it didn't go
very far um but I think it's important
that we take uh into consideration what
is too often happening uh with consumers
and this goes back I think a little bit
to the bill herd that I came in on uh
hb76 regarding paperless
billing what what has happened and what
I've got several seniors that have
called me and complained is that all of
a sudden their credit rating goes down
or they get a notice from a credit
company a credit collection company and
they didn't know that they owed a
balance on their hospital bill or that
they didn't uh owe um or that they owed
uh something on a consumer transaction a
balance that they had no idea
uh we all know that the M United States
Postal Service does an excellent job
when they do an excellent job um I just
got a Christmas card
yesterday often times too often the mail
doesn't come directly through what does
come through is the uh priority post
although it sometimes takes long for
that I had some um paperwork that I was
uh trying to deliver to an individual
took six weeks to get from brain tree to
Hudson I could have walked down and back
in that time well maybe not
but the thing is if you're going to push
someone into credit
collections spending $270 cents to send
a certified
notice is
not an overly um honorous burden on the
company or the entity whether it's a
small mom and popop shop who doesn't
necessarily have a lot of collections
because their cash or credit card or
debit card but for a hospital or uh
larger business
$22.70 I think the uh the cost analysis
for a letter is $5 so make it
$8 cost on a bill is not that of an
honorous event and it benefits both the
enti and the consumer the consumer knows
that they owe a balance and it gives
them a chance before their credit is
affected to resolve the issue and the
entity that has a a balance
due knows whether or not the consumer
still lives at that address because they
get their card
back and if when it comes to court if
they decide to sue the individual if the
amount is large enough for them to sue
like from a credit card company or
something like that they have a positive
notification when they go to court
saying hey we gave this guy every chance
and nothing happened so I look at it as
as a as a win-win even though it does
require uh somebody to do something uh
on the collection side uh with that Mr
chair I'd be happy to answer any
questions that the committee or people
in the audience may
have okay so um before I take a question
I make sure I understand so you're not
looking for that the person has to
actually
get the um the the certified letter
there there you that let's say the
certified letter comes back and they say
it was undeliverable the the person
refused it or didn't collect it or you
know the post office and post office if
you get this notice that they didn't get
it that that's not your problem you're
you're you're saying they'd still be in
compliance as long as they attempted to
send a certified letter yes I thought
that was clear but if not that's fine
and it doesn't necessarily have to be um
a certified letter there are entities uh
out and about I think there's one over
in the the uh western part of the state
that actually goes out and will put a uh
what they call a a
door knocker notice like like we do when
we're campaigning uh on your door only
it has it's in a sealed envelope so it's
not publicly viewable for
fdcpa um requirements but that's also
possible if you have a a um a large
enough uh debt on uh say a mortgage or
something like that where they they want
to know um but yeah the attempt needs to
be made not necessarily the successful
completion of it yeah I guess the
problem I got was the word affirmative
because affirmative means that you
affirm that the person got it but I I I
read it I see that it does not say that
any actual physical affirmation has to
occur okay Mr chair yeah you could
probably strike out on line three the
word give and put down shall attempt
yeah something like that okay all right
uh first up is representative Aon with
the
question go ahead Max
oh sorry I was still on mute um
basically the same question as the last
not the last time the bill before but
this these rules apply to not the
consumer it's not consumer protection it
applies to the business so this this
would only apply to businesses that
operate in New Hampshire correct or is
this different because this is you know
before you go to a New Hampshire Court
this is this would be before you go to a
New Hampshire Court and uh that it
wouldn't apply to just New Hampshire
businesses it says a creditor it doesn't
say from where that creditor is
located and if a out of state entity
doesn't comply with New Hampshire law
well they've got no chance at all to uh
uh oh there's a term I forgot the name
of it um when um certify our results in
their own local
Court
clever okay uh representative
Bartlett
chair um thank you for taking my
question representative earie
um so all of the bills that people
get by paper don't count so if you're
usually you get a bill and it takes 30
days you're supposed to pay it then you
get another bill and it says your 30
days overdue and you don't pay it and
then usually it takes 60 days to go to a
collection so all of the other notices
don't count now we have to have another
notice to tell the person who owes the
money that that's going to go to a
collection Ser agency now is that
correct that uh it's up to the business
as to what time they want to do that uh
60 days uh is not my experience and I
and uh being forthright I I some what is
classified as collections but it did I
don't touch any money at all um for a
couple of different uh entities um 90
days they start to get worried
and 120 days is when normally this takes
place now if the letter goes and it's
not returned this is just a final
attempt for the business to know whether
or not the individual intends to to do
this and it gives the business uh
positive feedback if you will that this
person isn't going to pay the bill so
here I need I need the $50 I need the1 I
need the
$10,000 uh or what is it 33 cents on the
dollar is a is
a going rate I need that money so they
just ship it over unfortunately some of
the larger business businesses
particularly in medical billing um they
don't care about the individual uh they
they just Bam Bam Bam Bam next Bam Bam
Dam next you know without even
attempting to determine the situation
which the individual finds
himself further question may inquire
thank you Mr chair so I'm going to give
you an example here I got a bill
yesterday from cockett
hospital um going back to a procedure
that was done January 31st of
2020 and on the bill this is my first
bill for it it has places for 30 days
overdue 60 days overdue 90 days
so I if I don't pay this bill I'm
probably going to keep getting notices
so you're saying
that the the dead beat at this point if
you're 120 days out you're a
deadbeat um still needs another notice
to say that it's going to go to a
collection agency knowing that the
collection agencies if they
collect typically the um the business
gets about 50% and the collection agency
gets about 50% is that correct I don't
think it's 50% I think the business gets
a little bit less than that sometimes 40
what well that's IMM material that's IM
material yeah yeah yes want another
notice to go a final notice an
affirmative notice something that is
taking a step that that that is positive
to the individual to assure that you're
getting a bill now that's a year old I
got a bill from Southern New Hampshire
that was two years old last
week um and it turns out that that Bill
had been referred to collection this was
just last week uh I've had seniors in
town uh say that there's what's going on
I never new and then they go and check
their credit records and their credit
score is is down 10 15 20 points
because they're deadbeat quote
unquote because they're referred to a
credit collection company even though
they had no idea they owed the
bill because time with this one the 55
cent letter that goes to you is a lot
different than a
$2.70 return receipt letter because that
one is tracked and it has to be delayed
delivered it doesn't get burned up on uh
they have Turnpike in a mail truck or if
it does you know that it has been burned
up so if I get get this maybe what's
confusing is the two weeks and the
affirmative and all that what you really
want is that whenever an entity has
decided to send your name and debt to
collection okay whenever it is could be
the first month it could be two years
later
or whenever they want to do it whatever
they thought that you want them to have
leased have put something in the mail or
hung something on the door to say by the
way we just sent you out to collection
or are going to send you out the
collection no no they going you want the
notification so I'm saying you're conf
that's what gets people all worried
about timing and so you just want
whenever somebody has submitted a name
they they want to be you know CU you're
you're you're assuming that mean the two
weeks is going to give them enough time
to sell it I I I right now it takes two
weeks for a letter to get in the mail to
me okay because you know we got we got
all kinds of mail problems here so you
just want to make sure that if
somebody's name is ever being sent to a
collection agency that that they that
there was some letter or notice or
something to let them know that they've
their name has now been sent over there
yeah yes in in essence that that I would
settle for that I prefer pre
notification but what you're talking
about uh Mr chair would be a I think
beneficial to everyone involved
particularly to a consumer who what I
owe this Bill here's my 10 bucks why are
you sending it to collection you never
bother to send me a you know you know
the normal arguments that come out but
yes I agree with you sir okay
representative aberson has a question
another question uh thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question in
the middle I'm seeing this this question
or the statement No debt collector shall
leave a message of debt on a recording
device I I assume that that means that
uh that that's not going to count as a
notice but what it just says is a
standalone statement I'm remembering I
think it was a Tom Hanks movie someone
was calling uh uh Tom Hanks and and ends
up arguing with him for about a minute
and then realizes that it's just an
answering machine does that does that
mean we're we're just adding this as a
standalone that you can't leave a
message to call back it's already
illegal under federal laws to to do that
okay so but then we don't need a state
law on top of the federal law well there
is some question as to whether or not a
phone call made between two parties
within the same state uh whether or not
the Fair Credit de uh fdcpa
applies so yes yes it's it was yeah if
you want to strike it fine it's not that
important uh but that was just uh
reminding people that they can't have a
message on the public uh uh phone call
and that does not uh address affirmative
notification
leaving a voicemail message well it's
funny that you but you did allow them to
leave a you know a big sticker on or
post some note on the door so every
driving by can see that but but you
don't want any message on the answer no
but if you notice it also says that that
has that has to be done in a solid
envelope Mark confidential addressed
only with the customer's name I used to
work as a merchant Mariner and you'd
have a mariner out of the country for a
few months at a time and they would pick
up their phone and they would have a
thing where they' call the uh their own
answering machine back home actually
have a recorded device there to try to
see you know are there any debt
collectors or anything so it seems like
kind of a weird law that sometimes works
against you um I would know I've never
um done that I know that uh if you're in
the Merchant Marine or if you're in the
military services you can't collect the
debt anyway so
yeah okay so I'm gonna do something
which I haven't done before but I'm
going to say is anybody in the committee
room want to have a question have a
question and just nothing else I want to
test the mics you guys
okay so yeah it's very hard to hear you
guys and let alone see you okay um all
right and I assume you're all set max or
you still have another
question I lower your hand okay oh now
over the attendees
side I have two other people who raised
their hand so is that no I didn't I have
more people to testify so
um all right well I guess we'll just see
what this means uh I will start I'm GNA
allow them to talk I'm not gonna they
promote them so Rick blae did you sign
up to testify on this
bill as to
unmute
uh M un mute talking permitted yeah and
he's still muted all right
so and then but I can't are you are you
unmuted now
okay so Rick are you blaze are you
there maybe
not okay uh next I have New Hampshire
Landlord
Association
um I I guess I'll allow you to
talk and if you want to unmute ask to
unmute
did you sign
up yeah go ahead uh yeah can you hear me
okay yes I can okay great um thank you
for the time uh my name is Mike boony I
work closely with Nick Norman um I'm on
his core team um and I'll have to
apologize in advance I've never attended
one of these but I I'm filling in for
Nick uh as I said I'm on his core team
so I just wanted to um we have a
statement here and I just wanted to
speak real quickly on this one if I
could uh okay so you never did the visal
sign up process okay well I think Nick
Nick Norman he's done this many times
and I'm sure he we're doing this the
first time so he knows that he's done it
many times better than us there this is
our first day doing this so um I guess
the question I would have is is do you
mind just having that submitted to the
committee you know that if it's a if
it's a written testimony that you're or
a written statement you can certainly uh
go through and have it submitted to the
committee but yep uh Nick may have done
that already but I can certainly follow
up with him and make sure I have the
right person and we can get that
submitted no problem okay okay because I
I don't I mean I don't know we do have
the time but I guess um my preference
would be for you to just submit it uh
because you don't and because I'm not
terms of I I could promote you to have
you testify but um is it if it's
important to you that you speak you know
see everybody when you testify but
otherwise if you're willing to submit it
that'd be
great all right uh yeah go
ahead no I I just I I was just gonna say
it's only it's only like a paragraph it
would probably take 30 seconds but if I
understand your time your time is of the
essence so we can certainly just submit
um we do have a little time because we
have nobody else U was testifying so if
you want to go ahead and and read that
paragraph into the file that's great but
you do I guess I don't know Pam can he
submit his name later afterwards so at
least we know who his information yes if
he goes to the um the website on the
general the general court website and
and
registers today um he'll be included in
the the testifying list okay great all
right so go ahead and uh with your with
your
testimony okay um so I I guess the
concerns we have is by the time
the the bill goes into collection the
debtor is well aware of the debt um the
bill is also not practical because it's
making creditors give notice to debtors
before referral to a collection agency
when the Creditor may not even know the
address or location and that's really
the tough thing is that for
landlords where we have a person who
leaves owing rent without notice it's
difficult if not impossible to even give
this notice because former tenants they
they oftentimes especially if they owe
money you you don't know their
forwarding address you don't even know
where they went um so um you know
tenants in such circumstances you know
they don't leave their forwarding
address uh they may have moved out of
state and the collection agencies with
additional resource uh may be able to
locate a formal ten former tenant but
smaller landlords you know without such
resources they may not have that ability
um in enactment of this bill basically
says to write off the debt by making it
impossible to provide the notice so you
know if you can't fulfill this notice
because you don't know where they are
then you can't really you know seek seek
the debt and I just have kind of a quick
proposal and maybe something a little
different is we're all required to send
the security deposit back or at least a
security deposit statement showing where
their funds went so
perhaps to propose this is to say that
after 30 days after they moved out you
send well I just lost you somehow you're
you're after days beyond that if you
haven't heard back from them and they've
made no contact and no effort to pay the
debt then uh allow the landlord to to
hire a collected agency that way it's
it's a passive type the clerk is not
able to hear yeah I can't I cannot hear
you you're all of a sudden I don't know
you're when whether your microphone or
something just suddenly uh died out on
us um so yep can you can can you hear me
sorry yes okay go ahead sorry what what
was the sorry what was the last bit you
heard the Bluetooth and went out H yeah
right um maybe it's just best that at
this point you submit your your
testimony uh to the committee and and
we'll we'll look at it from there okay
thank you no problem all right so I have
one other person uh Stephen Tower I
guess is also in the same position so
I'm going to allow you to tell us your
story and why you didn't sign up Stephen
uh I apologize representative H hunt I
did sign up but I did not sign up
particularly far ahead of time I signed
up at about 11:00 am I apologize the
procedures are a little new to me as
well okay so you're a Johnny come lately
so you're one of those people who we we
get where they put in a card even when
the testimony is going on um yeah I am
one of those people I apologize is it
possible that you could submit it in or
do you want to take uh five minutes and
just tell us what what you have to say
uh I I'll be faster than five minutes
okay um I'm from New Hampshire Legal
Assistant we're a nonprofit Law Firm we
provide free legal representation to
low-income families and seniors across
the state of New Hampshire um I am
testifying in support of this bill I I
do think there is an important benefit
to Consumers to receiving notice prior
to something being referred to
collections um and uh representative
Bartlett raised a good question of well
if they've already received notice that
they owe the money why do they need a
separate notice that it's going to
collections and I think that there there
is an important distinction when
something moves from just a debt owed to
being sent to collections because the
the sending of a debt to collections has
a concrete negative impact on the
consumer um even if once it is sent to
collections they pay off that debt
immediately to the collection company uh
there is a lasting impact on their FICO
8 score from that debt being referred to
collections even if they they have paid
it um and I one of the areas of law that
I work in at nhla is I run a a clinic
for for uh debtors in the Candia
District Court once a month or at least
they did before the pandemic and quite
frequently I would meet with people who
said I I thought I had paid this credit
card already or I thought I had paid
this medical bill and I I thought it had
already been resolved and then I got
this notice from the court I I I was not
I was under the impression that I had
paid this and my conversations with
these people indicate that many times
had they been aware that something was
going to be sent to
collections that they thought had
already been resolved in one way or
another they would take actions to get
that resolved before going to
collections but either it is an older
debt or it is a debt that was mixed up
with another debt that they had paid off
and they weren't certain of exactly
where the status of the debt going to
collections was um I I do think there is
a concrete benefit to people getting
that that notice before a negative
action is taken and I I'll note that a
very similar process to what is proposed
here is done by the utility
when they are pursuing a a late or
unpaid utility bill you know they when
they are when a debt is owed they will
send out a a pass to Bill notice but
before they move to do the negative
impact of the the disconnect on the
utility customer they send a disconnect
notice either by phone as described here
or um a posting in an envelope on a door
as is an option here it's it helps
provide clear notice that a a
substantial negative impact will happen
to the customer and um I think there's a
benefit to that um beyond that I I won't
say whether or not this particular bill
is the the most perfectly tailored means
of addressing that concern but I do
think it does address that
concern thank you great all right well
thank you very much and and I hope you
will submit that testimony so we have
have it in our files for us okay I'll be
happy so uh Jeffrey I see that you
represent gon you have your hand up you
have a question yes sir thank you Mr
chairman and I think my question would
probably be best answered by
representative erery uh and and
represent does have his hand up so
normally I would give if we have the
time I would give a sponsor a final bite
at the
Apple at this point representative URI
do you want who uh do you want to say
something uh and and take take another
question yes I will take a question okay
go ahead can I have a
suggestion yes go ahead oh you take the
question yes so represent you can ask
the question to rep okay thank you and
this goes to the uh the statement
concerning landlords trying to reach
tenants that they don't have an uh
forwarding address uh for uh if I
understand uh representative illery
your the requirement is only that the
Creditor provides affirmative
notification and that can be a certified
letter that they could send by mail to
the last known mailing address of the in
this case the tenant now delivery is not
required so if they and and certified
mail is usually not forwarded uh only
that the attempt was made it is
certified so that the Creditor the in
this case the land Lord would have
affirmative notice I did send this
notification but that it didn't get
delivered is not on me and it's not the
fault of the Postal Service it's just I
sent it to the last known to be in
compliance with this law I sent it to
the last known mailing address and
that's all that's required of me is that
an accurate
description uh yes and thank you for the
question that would be an accurate
description it would be a benefit to the
small land uh owner plan
damn
phone uh it would be a benefit to the uh
uh landlord because it would give him
the opportunity to say particularly with
the returning of the funds I've made
this attempt this it's documenting the
attempts that have made I would also
suggest to the small land um landlord
that there's a simple skip Trace hack
[Music]
um boy you ow lots of money to the
committee now yeah
well I'm at home I'm not in the
committee room uh the what would
happened is that uh if you take the
envelope and if you put down on the
envelope address correction
requested you will get the new
address of the um person who was moved
away from the house that's just a skip
Trace hack that uh that is in there
so it's just one of the ways you can uh
find out that new address but at any
rate uh to answer your question directly
representative gon yes the attempt is
the key thing and if it helps a person
uh as was indicated by uh the uh uh
lawyer that spoke earlier it's
benefiting everyone and uh I think it
benefits both the debtor and it uh
affects the benefits the
Creditor okay is that answer your
question representative gson uh yes sir
thank you okay well put your hand down
uh and I have another hint of this uh uh
Rick blae did you I see your hand is
still up is that can you hear me now yes
we can oh I'm sorry about earlier today
and I did go online and register it was
easy oh good um but I'm in opposition as
a landlord again uh it's the eviction
process when we go through a district
court for an eviction notice to have the
tenant removed at the same time we get a
rid of possession we get a collection
meaning the judge basically orders the
payment so basically we we already
circumvented the notice process because
we went through the eviction process but
from a creditor perspective that tenant
now is being told by the judge to pay
and it becomes a judgment against the
tenant on their credit
so I guess this is creating a quagmire I
understand that the intent of the bill
but from a landlord's perspective it's
also becoming part of judicial process
now on the eviction notice when we go
before a
judge that's all I wanted to a
recommendation for your testimony thank
you all right uh I guess now I have no
more hands up so I'm G to hopefully we
uh have worked this one and so I will uh
read the blue sheet here and um I have
sure I have the right bills is 109 yeah
good uh Michael McCary um is a lobbyist
from Collectors Association as opposed
to the bill um Tom pla uh represented
pla uh is um supports the bill uh Ellen
scaroni uh um is who represents
Consolidated Communications is opposed
to the bill uh Eric
rban uh who is a member of the public uh
supports the bill and finally Alvin C a
member of the public is oppos to the
bill and with that we'll close the
public hearing of U House Bill
109 um and we'll then go into recess
until
1:15
and I guess than you Mr chair yeah and
thank you representa lri and you have a
wonderful
day Revenue estimates not
okay
okay all right so so Erin are you still
there in the committee
room oh it's lunch break thank you Pam
for putting up the lunch break yes we're
going to lunch John okay so is Aaron or
the speaker still around it's just me
and okay all right that's fine all right
all right we'll see you all at
1:15
okay
for
e
hey Chris hey
Connie hey Joyce
hi went for a walk walk it's kind of
gray down here Raw it's fabulous up here
because there's no wind no there's no
wind oh my God the last two days have
been brutal look at your face I know I
can
tell and I'm hot oh yeah I was I was
cold this morning I decided I have to
dress warmer because when you just sit
for a few hours you get really cold yeah
and I'm upstairs and we don't usually
heat the upstairs well me too that's the
same here yeah so I just turned up the
thermostat hey
Chris Chris say
hello
[Laughter]
nope uh hey Chris another Chris another
Chris he's on the phone
though we got to make sure he knows how
to raise his hand right we we went
through that we we got through it oh
good well I I was texting him hey Chris
Chris M I I was
emailing do you know do you know how to
raise your
hand I Christy pointed it out did you go
into uh participants and it's there I
was looking just across the bottom and I
couldn't find it so I was texting I
thank you chrisy for helping me out
remember I'm a neop fight just take some
practice all of us are getting it did
you get yeah did you get my my text
message I don't know which which email
did you send it to no I sent you a text
message to your phone number for my
phone number I I'll have to check it I I
didn't see I didn't look I'll check
texted Rich to get him to
[Laughter]
mute I actually screwed up when he did
have his hand
up and what was happening was is that I
I have to be careful that when I look at
my panelist list they have to keep
pulling scrolling down so that I can um
as long as me and pammer is still at the
top that means I can see because when
you raise your hand you immediately bump
to the top of the list yeah so I you
need you need a bigger computer John I I
got a 17 screen how much bigger do you
want takes up a lot of desk
space but I do have a second I have a
huge computer so I can have everything
on there and it doesn't take any yeah
one of those Big Mac Mac screens there I
liked it when when I was when I was
still working we had three monitors you
know three screens so we could move from
one to another it was great I loved it I
don't I don't have that kind of room on
my desk like a traffic controller yeah
it felt that way some
days so were we allowed to have beer
during the
hearing soda soda me too I got the
same right doesn't show that you have
well it counts to where you are you have
to you know you have to pull it back
yeah and then what if your phone rings
do you have to pay five bucks that's
right well if we had a coffee fun but uh
I I had my phone un mute and then all of
a sudden it wasn't on mute so I I must
have in my frustration throwing papers
around I must have taken them mute off
the phone so I bet Chris Maier doesn't
know that rule he does now I told
him well then the other the the the
fuzziness of his beard or hand oh
Stapleton yeah that was weird I kept
thinking because it was so consistent
that it was like a phone thing you know
like a phone glitch but you know ter I
don't
know if he has a mic right down below
and he was shuffling his papers or
something it could have been something
like that I don't even know where my mic
is I don't know how anybody can do this
stuff on their phones and stuff like
that absolutely how do you one of the
important lessons I've learned over the
years is that the apps on your phone are
not the same apps on your computer it's
it's a different
app and so and and what's on your phone
is is stripped down it's you know it's
Dom Minimus and um and so I won't order
things I won't do any I just I will not
do them on my phone CU I well just a
puny
and K I think it takes practice too
because I know occasionally I'll call my
son in in the UK and if I catch him you
know if he's out somewhere I'll pick it
up on the phone and he knows how to do
it well yeah you but simple things like
that is fine you know I mean I do
FaceTime and I know the person's picking
up so but what about teachers ordering
stuff teachers teachers have to deal
with they have to go into the school
teach the students in the school and
teach the people that are the students
that are remote at the same time not
easy so Jane that's how the hybrid thing
works is that they're teaching the same
class but some of there and some aren't
yes oh boy that's nuts I thought it was
different
days yeah in in Manchester the uh
seniors went back to school
yesterday um and then slow the other you
know students will go in but uh um prek
through second or third have been in
schools all
along to send them was closed because of
Co yeah right right the metrics the
[Music]
metrics well okay we're almost there um
so I I do have an announcement to make
and and that is that I have been blessed
or we have been blessed with our two
extra days in February so uh for
everyone to keep in mind that we'll have
full days both Tuesday and Wednesday
next week and the following week and so
that means that next th next Wednesday I
have scheduled uh the will we EXA those
two bills that we heard that are have to
be out early Wednesday what time about
because I have a county meeting too the
Third it'll be the third at 11:5 oh
that's the same time as my County
meeting I'll pick Commerce County
delegation have meeting in the middle of
the week like that I know I know I'm
good I'll just I'm gonna go to
Commerce right right yeah we I have a
sube but not until Friday because we
won't do anything on a
Friday I I I have never in my career
have ever done anything on a Friday I
was counting on that no I I mean I would
owe always you know go either side of
the Tuesday Wednesday Thursdays and me
one year we really did have you know I
think you were talking about we had like
80 70 80 bills and I was able to just
squeeze them all in there and just get
it done but I the idea of you know
Mondays and Friday mean I'm on the
county my County delegation we're do
Monday mornings but which is now
conflicting with the Chairman's meetings
right exactly so that's why I made this
one Friday because um our leadership
will be on Mondays when you're having
your chairs and vice chairs okay so uh
we'll open up the public hearing on uh
make sure I have the right bill
number if it's Tuesday it must be
Belgium okay so this is House Bill 313
oh this one boy I all of a sudden my
mail is blowing up under the list okay
so 313 so um I'll ask the sponsor to
raise his hand so that I can I can
invite him to speak there he is okay and
and I'm now promoting to panelist
Glenn and good afternoon and uh welcome
to the Commerce
Committee nice
dog is that a lab you're still muted
Glenn Glenn you can hear me or you're
you're muted
can you turn your mute off I don't
know
uh I dare try to un oh there you
go sorry about that I I'm new to all
this stuff um uh thank you Mr chair um I
now that we can talk I I'll let you
continue what you were saying I'm
inviting you to speak and introduce your
bill okay okay I appreciate yall taking
the time to hear this bill I think it's
pretty important there are homeowners
associations that are really tough and
uh let me get back into what ham radio
is it's a very important thing if some
some of you may know when uh emergencies
arise such as Katrina
911 Boston bombings they have to fall
back on ham radio and we have volunteers
all over the country to help with that
the problem is that you have to practice
this stuff in order to be good and uh
you have emergencies to have to come up
your batteries go dead you gotta think
on the on the Fly and and uh go so the
problem with some of the home owners
associations is they will not allow a
single
antenna I wish I could show you uh but I
guess I can't I don't know why my dog's
up there but I've got a camera here but
anyway
I I've got an antenna here that's 12 in
I've got one some of you may remember
the old um when you had your nice
stereos your cwoods how you had that
antenna come up and then it would tee
off to the sides I have a one here I
wish I could show you that's illegal
they if they see that that you've
violated the rules and all we're asking
for is um a reasonable accommodation I
have another one that's 80
feet long but it connects to your house
and then you can take the other end to a
tree and with that all you see is a
piece of wire that is less than an
eighth of an inch thick but it's 88 feet
and uh I mean nobody could ever pick it
up so I just you know we we're trying to
make a reasonable accommodation and I
would like to make uh one other comment
before we go on is I have an amendment
uh in the process I'm not sure how
that's all working I haven't been
emailed yet but in the bill on section
one uh Part D it says uh let me get let
me get to it here antenna support
structure means a structure such as a
tower Pole or Mast used to support one
or more
antennas the amendment removes the word
tower there will be no Tower just uh
like a flag pole can be turned into an
a g her but we don't want a tower so
that's going to be
removed thank you okay um do any members
of the committee have a have a
question and uh representative Bartlet
you may thank you Mr chair thanks for
coming before our committee um
representative Aldrich um we had this
bill um a couple of years ago and we
retained it in committee and then it was
killed um one of the problems that that
I have with the bill is that this bill
would override what a homeowners
association is already agreed to for
their um members and I I do have a
problem with that and you I obviously
the intent of the bill is to override
what the homeowners association has
already agreed to
yes you believe is that what you believe
or yes that's true and believe me uh I'm
not sure who's on there but I am far
from uh one to get the government
involved with something I'm more
inclined to get them out but the with
the importance of ham radio in
emergencies all we're asking for is a
reasonable combination like I was trying
to say the the the first two antennas
that I met mention would be in your
house but they're illegal they would can
find you or whatever the rules they have
and I just I don't think that's fair and
I think that you know uh they don't ever
make the reasonable accommodations for
it and I think that they should so as
much as I hate getting government
involved I have to you know for this
plus I G to I didn't get a chance to
look it up but there's a federal bill
that would allow uh the same and more
because that's how important the uh FCC
thinks that it is and if we get further
down the line I'll I'll get that
information for
you okay uh res representative van
hton thank you and thank you for taking
my question I'm looking at the first
page um of the bill and I'm looking
under Community Association which is the
definitions uh section and it basically
says this is line 13 commonly known as
Homeowner Association now I live in a
condo I live in a condo association uh
is there an attempt to to bring all of
those different umbrellas under the term
Community Association or or is that
something that will hamper your
bill uh I'm I'm not sure could you
repeat the question for me please yeah
maybe I need to back up a step what is
the difference between a homeowners
association and a condo
Association or is there a difference
because I believe there
is well I I didn't I I don't know that
there is or there isn't um but I don't
see why it would shouldn't apply to both
you're asking for a reasonable
accommodation for an antenna uh even
some of the bigger ones can be in your
attic but under the HOA rules they are
illegal I
mean it just I mean it's it's very
important that emergency communications
exist cell towers they use the uh they
shut them down because bombers can call
in with cell phones so it's a very
important thing and we have to be able
to practice it you just can't jump in uh
to an emergency when you haven't been
able to practice turn your radio on you
don't know that it
works uh so that that's the important
thing is the practice and that's why we
need a reasonable accommodation
we we meant to pull that Towers out of
there because we all know what towers
are they're big they're
ugly everything that we're trying to get
in this bill is minimal it's hard to see
eighth of an inch wire even though it's
88 feet and if it's black it Blends in
almost all the time I have one that's
copper and it's tainted through the
years to that green that the copper gets
and it's barely noticeable and that's
what we're trying to get is to allow
people to uh be able to practice with
something that isn't going to mess up
the uh the beauty of of your
neighborhood follow up please yeah
follow so just to you clarify on your
previous question um so yes this would
imply to every in both home in if you
that says say you weren't really a condo
but you had a you know some kind of uh
uh land you know homeowners association
it would apply to everybody both of them
go ahead with your question okay and I'm
also looking here and again uh just just
to give you some kind of background uh
I'm currently in a condominium unit at
this moment there are eight units in the
building in which I am this states that
uh common areas such as rooftop um can
be used according to your bill would
that be somewhat cumbersome if all the
eight owners of the units in my building
were to do that and would there be any
kind of impact to say our cell service
or your uh internet service or any of
that sort of which you're
aware um well I'm not really sure about
the uh condo part but it'd be
really unique if all eight people uh put
an antenna up there but uh what and they
they would be allowed such as uh there's
are antennas that are just like the Dish
Networks so if you have eight of those
with Dish Networks or say seven and one
doesn't have it but they have a ham
radio you still have eight Dish Networks
up there uh uh
dishes and just a quickly follow up if I
may uh I did say there are eight units
but that means that there are more than
eight residents and if each and one of
us decided to have a a radio I think the
number eight could become Amplified
thank you for your testimony and for
your I guess I had intervenience if if
all eight want to do it and they have
the owners then they would vote to say
to allow them all do it so the issue
really is is what happens if you have a
Homeowners Association of eight and you
only have one homeowner who wants to do
this and the other seven don't want them
to screw holes into into the to the roof
shingles and they don't want any any
antennas or they think their antenna's
ugly and I remember the first time I
ever one of these bills it was someone
who wanted to hang a flag the US flag
and he was having he was getting uh um
Flack from his his neighbors so so it's
it's the idea of that in this case that
if it's a minority because obviously if
it's a majority then there shouldn't be
a problem okay next is representative
Herbert you there
Chris he was
here there he is
um I just a couple of questions Glen
because I don't I'm not that uh
conversent with ham
radios but um I'm curious if an antenna
is
remote uh not on a building say out in
the woods
somewhere uh but it's on common
land
uh would that would that uh one Tower be
able to be accessed
uh by uh multiple ham radio guys or is
it uh each each ham radio has a specific
uh
antenna well uh there first of all let
me State there's no Towers that's being
removed uh it's already been to
legislative Services I called them today
uh but yes everybody needs their own
antenna for their own radio just like
your car needs an
antenna
um
like I said they're not they don't have
to be intrusive and ugly no I I uh I
voted for your bill to begin with Glen I
was just there was just some things that
I uh I was interested in because we do
have already have Towers they're there
and uh I don't I don't see why the state
cannot
allow just like they allow all those
individual uh you know for cell tow uh
for cell cellular communication that
they wouldn't
allow uh or or in fact order uh a
network of ham radio towers that would
cover the whole
state I'm just trying to I'm just trying
to see if that's even
possible uh the cell towers uh are one
thing but the uh handam radio towers we
have we have them I I'm president for
the central New Hampshire amateur radio
club and we have one on Gunstock and we
have to turn it down to 19 Watts instead
of the 50 that it's capable of because
we were interfering with some stations
um I think there were radio stations FM
in
massachusett okay so so there's an
interference problem if you start
doing uh well you can you could we
worked around that by lowering the power
but you still had you know it's it's
like the a radio and it is a frequency
just like uh FM
104.9 okay everybody's radios can tune
into that but you can't talk with ham
radio we tune into those frequencies and
we transmit as
well okay thank you all right great
thank you uh representative Terry you're
up next for a
question thank you Mr chairman um for
those members who are unfamiliar with uh
amateur radio or so-called ham radio um
amateur radio operators are regulated by
the Federal Communications Commission so
these these are not U individuals who
are just purchasing equipment and
deciding that they're going to uh
broadcast uh anywhere within the country
or around the world This is highly
regulated and has been for decades by
the Federal Communications Commission
uh if I may direct a question to
representative Aldrich uh did I
understand you to say that there are or
could be Community
associations that
prohibit uh individuals from erecting
antennas uh no matter how small they may
be within their own
residences and if that is if that's
correct
I'm wondering on what
basis uh legal basis they can they can
regulate what you have in your in your
own in your own home or your own
Dwelling Place um the second question
that I have let answer that is um with
respect to retained two years ago did I
understand that to be the case that the
Bill's history was that it was retained
two years ago and if so I have a
question is that
accurate uh I think it was a retain but
uh I really don't recall the
details what is the history of this bill
is it brand new or does it have a
history did uh did I have I don't have
my fingertips Pam did you sp send out
something on on this it has a history we
retained it and then we killed it all
right um so can somebody outline for me
the outline of the history of this bill
it it was representative all I'm sorry I
was addressing representative Aldrich or
do I have yeah you go ahead you're
asking a you're asking him for that he
representative ald were you the one who
sponsored this legislation
previously yes I was and um I don't know
if anybody is familiar with the a rrl
it's the American radio relay
League um they helped write this bill
and uh I think part of the problem was
uh we had a couple people that had test
I tried to find it but I couldn't that
uh and I think we uh addressed all the
issues the towers is gone and uh you
know like I said the whole thing is we
just they're they're pretty much like
stealth antennas um and we are a lot
different than CB anybody can get a CB
and can talk all what they want but uh
we are FCC regulated our licenses are
good for 10 years we uh practice for
emergencies and a lot of the events are
fun if anybody knows what climb to the
clouds is I provide emergency
communications for that event as well as
about 30 others we that gives us
practice out in the field and that's
part of what we need to do that's for
local stuff the antennas that I'm
talking about that are really stealth
are for HF I've talked to Colombia
Germany Poland and around the world and
I don't even do that part of it much I'm
more for local emergencies and that's
why I started with this and that's why I
think this bill is so important that we'
be able to practice when that emergency
comes that we have
the uh done the leg work to have this
just step right up and replace
everything else that's gone
down thank you Mr chairman uh I was
attempting to establish a baseline here
with respect to the legislation proposed
legislation that we have before us and
how it may have been similar or
different from the legislation that was
submitted reportedly submitted in the
past and what the objections were uh in
the past first asking the sponsor I
don't want to be misunderstood if there
are colleagues who can provide
additional information to me and with
your um with your permission I'd be
happy to hear from them thank
you um I guess but I'll I'll interject
here um so theoretically I as a someone
as a chair I'm not supposed to be
telling you how I feel you know this is
supposed to be an open hearing and
something like that but I can tell you
what the prent was and where I was with
this bill and then you can take it for
what it's worth um we have another bill
coming up later which is um uh adding uh
uh installation of solar energy systems
to to the roof of a house okay the RH
the issue um for me it comes down to is
that um when someone buys into a condo
or buys into a community organization
whether they know it or not um they are
buying into a whole new u city or town
or you know regulated body that has a
democratic process in which they're
going to vote for and against things um
theoretically if you're someone who uh
if you're a ham radio thing I my
recommendation is that you would you
would check it out before you bought the
condo that whether the condo is going to
let you put an antenna on the roof or
not um and if there if they're not then
you probably that's probably not the
property you want to buy into um if
someone just became ham radio out later
on and said GE I want to do ham radio
now well it's again it's problematic
because you got to get your neighbors
you got to get the community you got to
get people to go with it and and so in
terms of this or the solar on the roof
or like that um my my position has
always been um you that you know buy or
beware when it comes to buying into a
homeowners association um you're you're
buying into a group of people and and
you better you know make sure you've
done your homework and making sure that
they're okay with what you're doing for
the legislature just unilaterally come
back and say well notwithstanding the
fact that you are a little democracy and
you know have a little your own
government we're going to tell you what
you can or can't do in terms of the
rules and that and and that's that's
where I would say in the past I have I
have voted down these type of bills so
so Mr chairman you're citing that as one
of the your perception and your
recollection that that's one of the
major reasons why this bill um was
retained and did not Advance yes or no
we retained it to try to work through
some of the see where there was some
issues to be worked through and and at
the end of the day we ended up um not
voting uh not for future recommend uh
future legislation and and was the
opposition extended to um inside as well
as
outside the idea that you have an
antenna inside your house like for
instance I always thought well because a
lot of them they have a little roof it's
roof in space between the roof and your
ceiling that if you stuck it up in there
you'll be able to have a good signal I
don't know the nuances and all the
Dynamics of it but again it is something
that this is something you as an
individual need to work out with your
homeowners association with the group
that that that ask the state to
intervene seems inappropriate to me Mr
chairman some of us are so old here that
we may remember rabbit ears on top of
our black and white televisions it would
seem to me by analogy that the condo
associations would also be prohibiting
rabbit ears on top of a television set
inside someone's house or bedroom thank
you very much yeah I I hear you and
that's leg question okay so you can put
your hand down if you I'll put your hand
down for you uh representative ham
you're
next thank you thank you Mr chair um I
just wondered and I'm I'm quite familiar
with um condominium associations and and
you're right it would have to be a
majority vote of of all the members in
the association to change the
association rules um and that would only
um address that particular Association
I'm just wondering um whether I do know
um cellular towers we have four of them
in um our community and and there's
about probably to be two more in the
general area to get good Communications
up and down the valley and I do know um
because I'm chair of the planning board
that um we cannot uh say no to anything
that's Homeland Security that's that
enhances Emergency Services we have to
make provision for uh police uh and
those kinds of Emergency Services now I
don't know whether um amateur radios
Falls within that and that maybe um a
regulation change I do know it's
FCC and we're we're regulated by FCC
also I don't know whether um and they do
provide uh a a service in emergencies
they are recognized as an integral part
of Emergency Services in case of uh any
kind of a Homeland Security or emergency
situation so you know I don't know
whether there needs to be FCC regulation
changes so therefore this technology
ends up on those telecommunication
Towers or whether this is an important
enough service that perhaps the
community might um provide that kind of
a service they have Towers on top of
their um police what is your what is
your question I'm sorry uh so my
question is is that is that the way to
address it it's certainly not going to
get addressed on on the the um
Association condominium side of things
but is it an important enough Public
Service safety issue to perhaps um
justify uh you know some sort
of in other places in the law holy
dude oh yeah that's the big key your
need to uh mute oh I'm
[Laughter]
sorry and and Chris you need to mute
also oh am M I'm sorry I thought I yeah
yeah okay all right um so so uh so um
your your question representative ham is
is is this could be done some other way
rather than uh forcing just uh
homeowners associations to deal with the
problem uh representative Aldridge you
want to respond to that yeah there's
there's no way uh that we could like do
the towers I mean we have we have what
are called repeaters and that's good for
local stuff and what a repeater
basically does it can take a five watt
walkie-talkie radio it sends it up to
the tower the tower transmitted at uh
anywhere up to 50 Watts like I said
earlier we had to back ours down on gun
stock to 19 or 16 Watts so we didn't
have interference so I mean we always
taking this stuff into consideration and
uh I I think it's it's very important uh
to uh get to representative hams point
when if we had a three-week ice storm or
any other natural storm that we've had
uh we could only be faced with ham radio
and just so that you know in Katrina we
have a relay system so if you have a
family member in that was in the
hurricane and you didn't hear anything
we can relay a message from one H to the
next and it just goes all down the line
we get a message somebody will drive to
your house and try to find you if we
have to or the police station and then
they'll relay a message all the way back
up and I can tell you uh that you know
your family members fine we found them
at the you know the local shelter and
everything's good so it's a very
important for emergencies and it's very
important to practice you just can't
throw a kid a keys to the car and expect
them to operate like uh somebody that
knows how to drive and in order to do
that he has to have some practice so he
goes to school or his parents teach him
whatever the case may be but I would I'm
telling you I I Mr chair you especially
I understand your point of view on it I
would be the same way I mean I've had
Liberty friends what other things you
want the government to get you know and
I'm like you know this one is really
important or I wouldn't be doing it
believe me fair enough thank you you all
said representative
ham okay uh representative hton is
next uh thank you um the upper area of
my I'm in a floal and the northern third
of my florial is basically condos uh and
condo associations and I'm always
Fielding questions about these I find
that many of the constituents who live
here are quite territorial about
associations therefore my question is
this um who would be the enforcement
agency and to whom would the penalties
uh the penalty fines
go well that's a good question uh
unfortunately I don't have a good answer
on that one I can certainly research it
uh you want to know who's going to
enforce it well in the leg isation it it
does indicate charges or penalties that
are assessed and uh I don't know if the
association the condo association would
be the enforcement agency or if this
falls into some kind of departmental
element of legislation um and who
collects the money and who keeps the
money is the other point of that
question they would have to the the home
homeowners association would have to
take that homeowner to to court it it
does may I follow up it does say that
there are charges or penalties
that precede any kind of Court action so
what uh
uh uh yeah I'm not a lawyer nor do I
pretend to be one so it might be a
missing element of this and deeds and
you know if you're trying to sue
somebody for deed so the statute is
under you one one person would takeen
the other person to court so right but
it again there is that step before going
to court which involves charges and
penalties I just want to know who's
who's preview that is who who handles
that who keeps the money maybe that's
why we retained it the last time okay
all right thank you the answer to that
question thank you representative all
right uh representative AEL you're next
yes thank you and thank you for uh for
your testimony today um uh
representative Aldrich I believe you
said that you were either the prime
sponsor or uh one of the co-sponsors of
this bill when it came before us early
uh in earlier sessions is that
correct yes it is we uh we knew there
was some issues so we re worked it it's
not the same bill and like I said so far
uh the only part that I've seen is wrong
is that the you know the towers uh will
not be there that word will be removed
and uh as soon as I get the I don't know
if they'll send it to you guys or to me
or what but I called and made that uh
request this morning when I saw follow
follow up please for the question
inquire thank you um as I recall then
the earlier bill and I somehow think it
it came before us
twice um uh was that the earlier Bill
did include towers that were re pretty
tall maybe a hundred feet or more and
that most of the the objection as I
recall was to to that um so this would
be a different bill because it doesn't
have that and I don't recall there being
I'm sorry I will get to my question I
hope okay um I don't recall there being
discussion of of interior antennas that
were not visible
outside of uh the homeowner's property
um so that would be something we would
need to look into that would we not I
that would be uh to to narrow it down to
something that that no one else can see
that's inside your
unit um that that would I would venture
to say you probably can do that now with
no problems because nobody else in the
homeowners association will know you
have one so well not entirely true if
for some reason they needed to come in
and see it it's against the rules and to
get back to those rules real quick all
those were pretty much cookie cutter
somebody came up with it and they pretty
much use the same thing I live in a
mobile home park and a co-op and all the
co-ops they they almost always do the
same thing so then we have to go and to
our rules committee and change them
individually but they try to come in and
do them and the homeowners associations
do not like changing the rules like the
people you know that actually own the
co-op so do you have uh an an anecdotal
story in which a homeowners association
actually enforced this uh an prohibit
hams for someone who had an antenna
inside their house I don't but I can
certainly look for that I I would hope
so because I mean because like I say I'm
hardpressed to believe that there's ever
that that that if any Homeowner
Association in terms of we've seen the
rules are usually because you had you
built something on the out outside of
the building and put it on the roof or
the siding I mean we had one bill the
guy was he had a snow blow he was
snowblowing his backyard so his dog
would have a place to go and the
homeowners association the condo
association cracked down on him because
they said you're not allowed to snow
snow blow on your lawn but um other on
their lawn which is the obviously
Community own so I guess if I I I I I I
would be at least for myself personally
I would might feel a little bit
different if you could show me that that
that actual homeowners association was
so anti-am that they would not even
allow you to have an antenna inside your
house if you could find one of those
stories I'd be interested in it so uh I
don't see oh representative gon
sorry oh thank you chairman and thank
you uh representative Aldrich uh I I I
think what I'm hearing is a misunder
standing on maybe not amongst everyone
here today but maybe amongst the public
and especially the homeowners
associations of the type of equipment
that might be installed the types of
antennas uh that would be installed uh I
think they have this picture in their
mind those unsightly antennas uh aerial
antennas like we had back as you know
back in the day uh and I think that's
what they or the or the small satellite
or even the huge satellite dishes that
that uh you know Megaton uh satellite
antennas uh so just could you describe
the type of equipment antennas or
whatever that would that be uh that
could possibly be installed on the
outside of the house that would be
considered quote unsightly that is
usually in the Aesthetics of a
homeowners association that they would
be the that would be the the source of
the objection how is this different from
those Aerials from the 70s
well they're mostly Towers uh for
example the thin wire I was telling you
about that can be dropped in a gutter it
could be hung From a
Balcony uh it can be go from your
balcony like I said a a a piece of just
electric wire less than an eighth of an
inch that's 80 to 160 feet can just go
from your place to a tree and hardly
ever be seen they have flag po antennas
that tune up to certain frequencies on
on there um did did I miss one of your
uh questions on
that no that seemed like is it no I I
all all I'm just getting at was the fact
that I think that there's just a
misunderstanding of of the actual type
of equipment I having lived in a
homeowners association before uh
everything is all about seems to be
about Aesthetics and aerial antennas and
satellite dishes are big no no uh that
in the color of your house and so I'm
sorry well I just if you can being able
to express the exact type of of
equipment that would be installed I
think is is you know why they would I
think that's what they have in mind and
so that's why there are these objections
it's just ignorance on their part so
well the the uh uh like the Direct TV
those dishes I don't know I think
they're kind of small compared to the
other ones they can actually be used for
that and I don't think homeowners
associations bar them do they again it's
really any individual Association what
they had decide and what they put in
there um based upon what you just
described to me I could see some
Association not liking 100 foot wire
stringing from the side of the building
to a tree um because that's that's just
like the guy who was snowplowing the
path for his dog um you know that I can
see an association having an issue with
just a wire yeah because it's anything
exterior because I think uh
representative gon's hit it right on the
nail it's it's Aesthetics and and and
unfortunately if you get into a
homeowners association you have to know
that some homeowners are very particular
about what they think their the
Aesthetics of their outside of their
building are to not only the color you
know the what you're painting or you
know the you know what type of shingle
they have on the roof I mean they can
get really you picky UN about it so I
assume that's what maybe what the issue
is but I don't know well that was just
one like I said you can drop that same
wire in a gutter and depending on how
long your gutters are you can tune that
up too uh I mean I probably shouldn't
have thrown that wire in except for it
is so
small I guess you'll have to give us an
example we probably need some more
anecdotal you know anecdotal stories of
what's going on in New Hampshire have
you how about how about actually exists
how about just for an idea an extension
cord you know the like the cheap brown
ones that's they're
connected yeah they might have rules
about Christmas lights and say well it's
it's one of those that's the thickness
and actually it's thinner than that than
one of not if you cut that in half and
had the two pieces it's smaller than
that okay I I think we get it I think
okay all right um are you all set Jeff
represent GRE you're all set I'm all set
thanks I'm I'm familiar with amateur
radio with numerous friends who are
involved so I I know I know all the
equipment that they use and that sort of
thing so yeah okay I've also been a
homeowners association so I know all
about those
two okay repres Parlin you're next thank
you um I'm sorry but I I I guess I have
to go back to the flag pole type Tower
so are you saying
that if I I live in a homeowners
association we've paid for underground
utilities but if this bill goes through
you can put out a flag pole with 180
feet whatever of wire to this flag pole
no and this bill would keep would would
force the homeowner association to
accept it no ma'am if you have if your
homeowners association doesn't object to
having flag pole and you would have to
probably go to your town and make sure
if you had or the well certainly to the
homeowners association that probably to
the town because if you're going to put
a flag pole in you're going to have to
be digging in that dirt so as long as
there's uh no objection for that you
would probably have to get a permit
you'd have to certainly get the
homeowners appro uh Association approval
but it's just a standard looking
Standalone flag pole has a wire running
up the
shaft and could be brought into
underground or along the ground depend
on how close it was to your house where
you would never even know it was
anything other than a flag pole so
there's nothing attached to it except
the flag on the
outside okay thank you okay um so we do
have other people uh testimony but I I
do see some more hands up I assume
you're all secy uh Joyce did you have a
question for representative
Aldridge yeah I don't want to be
laborist but thank you for letting me
just Express one thing uh I hear that
you're really that uh representative
Aldrich you're really trying to make it
seem as though this is not
objectionable but in your in your bill
on page two lines 13 through 16 you talk
about electrical
enclosures ground mounted control
enclosures and guide wire anchors that
have to be
screened and I if they're visible from
the street and it this sounds a little
bit like more than just a
wire what are we talking about screening
here that I'm sorry for that the I'll
have to get another amendment uh any
guide wires would be going to Towers
which we took out I just I just didn't
catch that part but thank you for for me
and I'll correct that okay thank you
thank you uh so like say we have uh some
more people who would like to speak so
uh representative Terry you uh you just
heard a question rever one minute y if
that thank you Mr chairman
representative Aldrich um as someone
who's familiar with amateur radio um I I
can see that there are members that are
struggling
today visually they're trying to picture
this so would you forward to the
chairman uh maybe three or four five
photographs that would be expressive
visually of what you have in mind in
terms of what the bill would would
permit or required to be permitted I
think that would be enormously helpful
if we could have everybody see exactly
what um what you have in your mind right
now thank you that would be no problem
I'm uh I don't know what's going on I
don't know why my dog's up here but I I
I can see s to the right you have to get
on your video and change your video
settings yeah well I was afraid I'd lose
you guys but if we can get towards the
end I can yeah send up you know send to
the committee U some photos of what
you're thinking about that would be
helpful I they to I certainly will I
could show you right now I have them
right here but I'll send them sure thank
you that'd be great thank you and Les uh
representative V hton did you w to do
this again or you want to wait till we
get some other people know I just want
to make sure that I have a a
clarification of something that I
referred to earlier um I live in a condo
eight units I live on the lower floor
there's a floor above me if the
gentleman above me had an antenna of
this sort up for his uh amateur radio is
there any chance that there would be any
interference to my cell phone to my
cable to my internet to any of that sort
or would I be free of that possibility
of
interference well the only time that the
the FCC is very clear anytime there's
any interference like that you have to
shut down immediately and then try to
find the cause and if you can't uh
ascertain what it is then you cannot
fire it back up so no there will be no
uh uh interference for any of that stuff
cell phones the only really the only
time anything like that would even
probably most likely be and remotely
happen is if somebody had like a th000
2,000 watt uh uh Power and I run most of
us run a 100 or less so there's been no
issues with
that thank you great thank you very much
uh so now well uh representative m is uh
I've just moved you over to the panelist
so um you're free
to Welcome to the Commerce Committee
thank you chairman hunt and the members
of the commit
uh and appreciate your time with the uh
issue here I want to make two uh points
one is that I live here at a condo in
New Hampshire and I have my antenna
totally confined to my limited common
elements it's all my back porch looks
like a bird feeder my nerv get curious
what's that say it's part of my weather
station but I also use it for radio
which is true so I think one compromise
you might consider if we're get stuck on
the outside of effects of the antennas
is to say let's keep it to the limited
common elements of the property it's on
your back portch and it's only in your
back courts it can't go anywhere else in
the building anywhere else outside of
the
building but I did want to talk on the
second point anecdotally about the uh
value of having trained radio operators
available for public surface and Public
Safety and I'll speak to the 2013 Boston
Marathon I served for about 20 years as
a radio operator for Boston Marathon in
2013 I was assigned to
dispatch dispatch means I've had about
half a dozen red cross stations and some
water
stations at the Red Cross stations I
have one person who's assigned to the
station Chief always be in their site
another person looking at the school bus
pickup points for runers becoming uh
exhausted to the point they can't
continue anymore where do they go we
direct them to the school bus pickup
point then I have a third operator who's
a floater his job is to make sure that
everybody else is doing their job and
he's got his eyes and ears out looking
for problems typically we see Runners
going down the course with distress we
with a call from a station up the course
saying Runner bib number so and so is
appears to be in distress We'll advise
our station chief of a runner that's
needs to be monitored we'll pass that
along and uh if necessary uh call for an
ambulance uh in 2013
typical marathon runner race uh TV was
on for a few hours they show Runners
going up Heartbreak Hill do some ancd
Donal interviews and they shut it down
and go to daytime programming but now
we're busy because most of the runners
are not Elite Runners most of the
runners are pretty good Runners but they
get tired and we get a lot of calls from
the medical stations
to uh get supplies get treatments and
sometimes call for an
ambulance in 2013 we got a call from
station and crew chief that um go silent
there's been two bombs that went off in
Boston don't say anything on the air but
be
ready then we got our
instructions instructions are stop the
runners at the Red Cross
station and we explained that to the
crew chief who probably knows it already
but we're there to help direct traffic
look for problems and assist so in my
sector the runners were then assigned to
the Newton City Hall where there school
buses to pick them up and take them to
the next point from there but the
important point of the training here is
that you need to have experience passing
traffic bath and forth about situations
in clear manner concise and the people
who need to
know and having a radio station at your
house gives you that training does it
have to be elaborate but you need to be
able to run drills where you have to
understand what's being talked about
which is complicated information copy it
clearly mark it down and and send that
in as a report these are called somewh
contest uh but there's a a lot of
intense activity to do this training and
Report accurately so I hope the
committee will support the bill in the
context of adding amateur radio
operators to the balance of Public
Safety people as backup we're not the
primary Communications but we're the
backup Communications so things go bad
there's people available to pass traffic
and to respond properly if they're call
up thank you Mr chairman great thank you
um does anybody have a questions okay uh
Connie representative van hton you have
a question yes thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative um please
excuse my ignorance and and I really
know very a little about this um are
most amateur radio operators involved in
networks of the type that you're talking
about or is that something that happen
sporadically in terms of community
need yeah we're actually called the
amateur radio service so the basis of
getting your license is for service
there's many ways to do that some people
do experiments with new technologies
digital modes of
communications uh many operate in local
public service events like I've been
doing
uh it's a wealth of
opportunities thank you quick followup
forther question me inquire are there
many people involved in these types of
activities or is it just a a small
minority oh quite a lot Boston Marathon
we have two to 300 ENT radio operators
we have at the Finish
Line um where they were very busy in
2013 because the cell towers were shut
down as was pointed out uh when there's
a penny problem and there's preps radio
controlled bombs Shel Towers go down
need backup Communications we were part
of that system there certainly private
radios that were used but we were part
of that
backup uh at the beginning of the course
there's a whole another activity going
on mustering all the runners uh separate
whole project they're up most of the
night but they go home early and then
most people like myself are in the
middle of the course between the the
initial rounding up of the runners the
start of the race with the Wheelchairs
and then the uh Elite Runners and then
the regular Runners it last till about
5:00 at night we're in about 12 hours
thank you thank you for indulging me I
really didn't know what thank you um
representative mcclear do you have a
question yeah I don't mean to show my
ignorance but uh I'm familiar with
marine radio which is obviously portable
I always thought of ham radio is being a
single station and not mobile but the
way you're talking it sounds like you're
mobile yeah it ranges from the handheld
walkie-talkies to a Mobile station in
your car to a home station that we're
talking about on this bill
today it's it's a broad band so okay uh
thank you very much Bill it's nice to
see you again and so next uh I'll ask uh
let's see who Bob bets if you there
raise your
hand uh
I don't see in a hand raised Bob bets
are you
around um next is Fred poppen gter
didn't I see that name Fred yeah Fred
would you like to speak okay good thank
you I will promote Fred to
speaking and welcome you're still muted
and welcome to the Congress committee
yeah thank you very much uh chairman
hunt uh I wanted to say a few things and
and be very brief the opposition that um
you will hear to this kind of a bill is
that uh these antennas are unnecessary
but you've heard from representative
home that without out outdoor antennas
you often have no useful ham radio
you'll hear that these
antennas can be
unappealing but basically we're trying
to B design a bill here where these are
virtually invisible antennas or they are
identical to antennas that are already
permitted under federal law like a TV
broadcast antenna uh satellite the the
tiny satellite dish antenna or a flag
pole uh in fact uh CI the Condominium
Association uh Institute is in favor of
flag poles uh and we can load use a flag
pole as an antenna without a need for
wires from it you run a feed line to it
underground you load the antenna that is
the flag pole is the antenna um and you
will hear that uh some of this may not
even be desirable uh but I suggest to
you that for New Hampshire it would
provide a training ground for not only
emergency skills but also technology
skills there's one other thing I'd like
to say briefly in that is can the
association vote to
allow the
antennas sadly frequently that's
impossible because the
prohibition on any amateur radio antenna
may be included within the common
covenants and restraints that run with
the land it may be
impossible to change that
Covenant unless perhaps you get not just
a majority vote but unanimous vote
frankly you're looking at something
that's impossible there because you may
not be able to even get to some of the
people who have the vote finally I'll
tell you that the kinds of antennas we
have proposed in this bill and if we've
miswritten it I'd be delighted to
rewrite it I'm the guy who typed it out
uh and I'm learning things all the time
from members of the committee are
antennas that are already permitted by
federal law for satellite TV or other
broadcast or wireless internet reception
we're not looking for different kind of
antennas we're only looking for
permission to use those kinds of
antennas for ham
radio a wire minimally visible
wire if you wanted to limit it to a
backyard I'd be happy to work with
people on writing that it suggests
antennas raised only in darkness and
unless somebody can see in the dark
there is no aesthetic problem there and
antennas perhaps uh no higher than a
roof line and in the backyard that
cannot be seen from the street and
finally the flag poles that are already
Allowed by federal law but to be used by
amateur radio in other words what we're
trying to do here is meet every
objection we hear and I hope the
committee will consider this bill
favorably or work with us to redesign
it okay uh is there any questions from
the
committee and uh I I would correct one
thing um we did have this issue many
many years ago um that when it comes to
Condo Association agreements that that
were written in the original Deeds um
that it it is an 80% vote that it does
not require to be unanimous we did
change that uh for for one circumstance
then I think it was changed again but so
I I I think that that's somewhat a
little looser but again um it does
require a very super majority um okay I
see no more hands raised thank you very
much and I have one more hand that's
rest it's uh Gary derario which I don't
have you Gary on my list at all so um I
guess what I'd like to do is just I'm
gonna allow you to talk so uh are you
did you want to sign up for it and
didn't have a chance to speak or and who
do you
represent
and there we go you can speak now Gary
okay thank you um and I apologize for
for not being signed up in advance I I
didn't realize I thought we just needed
to get on Zoom um I will try to be brief
I am an attorney and I partner with
Marcus Rico emeran Brooks my office is
in marac New Hampshire I'm actually um
speaking in my role as the chairperson
of the legislative action committee of
the Community Association
Institute uh which was referenced
previously um you know speaking bluntly
I I have to say uh this bill appears to
not just infringe upon Association
rights but uh really to rather trample
them I mean I'm I'm looking at the
language in here and not only are they
setting aside or seeking to set aside
covenants and restrictions that are
already on property and I've heard this
discussion already and commentary from
several people that um no one has to
live in these associations people make a
voluntary decision to do so and when
they do that they're agreeing to live by
these restrictions but this bill would
set those aside and it would do it in
favor of the hobbyist regardless of the
opinion of the rest of the community I
also see in here language that says that
the owner uh would not need prior
approval before installing some of this
equipment um that speaks against uh
associations in general because they all
have a requirement for approval even
where people have a right to install
something it's about the association
knowing what's going on and knowing that
it's being done properly I see language
in here that says that um someone
wouldn't be prohibited from using the
common areas including the roof for the
installation of this equipment and for
those who aren't particularly familiar
with associations um when you have the
unit um and that's under the ownership
of the unit owner and you have common
areas please know that the common areas
are not owned by a particular unit owner
and so what what this bill is also doing
is it's raising both constitutional and
property rights issues and questions
that would be very problematic because
uh to my knowledge uh there doesn't
exist another scheme within which any of
us uh have the ability to install any
type of equipment on property that we
don't actually
own um and there are going to be some
serious issues that could come into play
when people start drilling holes into
roofs and then the roofs start leaking
and then you have unit owners suffering
water damage who are other than the
people who put the antenna there in the
first place um and I think these are the
the
important questions that that sort of
speak to why this isn't good for
associations and I think that that that
really is um the question that that this
bill needs to look at uh or that the the
committee needs to look at when
reviewing this bill it's not a question
of the value of ham radio I don't think
any of us um would argue against it
being um a a valuable activity that
people engage in that's helpful at times
I think the issue here is a question of
property rights what this bill is
dealing with is the places where people
would be able to conduct this activity
and install this equipment without
restriction and unfortunately when it
comes to associations that already have
restrictions on record um it seems
inappropriate for the legislature to
step in um to to try to set that aside
uh towards the end of this bill we see
language this gets back to my point
about where really a trampling of the
rights of the association towards the
end of the bill uh we see
language about what the fines will be
I've never seen requirements of of what
Association fines would be for
violations of anything other than in
their own documents um so really
problematic stuff here also um if
there's a place where the committee
would like me to send it I'm happy to
send two documents that I've obtained uh
from Ci's National organizational Branch
they were involved um with a proceeding
that dealt with this issue before the
FCC and the documents that I've looked
at from them
indicate that this bill has been
proposed on a federal level and it's
been proposed and rejected multiple
times and that this bill as as sort of
another strategic Avenue has been
proposed to the FCC with the idea being
that the FCC would make a rule that
would preempt the covenants and
restrictions on Association property and
multiple times that has also failed and
so what you are being asked to do with
this bill is as the New Hampshire state
legislature to make a mistake commit an
error that nobody else has been willing
to do not the federal legislature and
and not the FCC and so I think it's
really kind of a big ask for you and a
bit of an unfair ask as well
um and like I say I'm happy to send this
information so so kri what you what you
do is um if go on to the the state web
or web page the house represented web
page and uh sign yourself up and in
there there will be a field for you to
upload um your testimony and anything
else that you wanna want us to see thank
you thank
you and then I have Dean Lennon who also
in the same position so I'm going to
click on you to allow to talk Dean but
I'm not going to upgrade you
because did you thank you repes
representative hunt can you hear me yes
we can thank you excellent I appreciate
the opportunity to uh speak I am uh also
an attorney uh at the same firm as Gary
we are law partners and I'm also on the
New Hampshire legislative AC action
committee uh uh as part of Cai New
England uh I don't want to reiterate any
of the points Gary made although I
certainly uh support everything he said
said um I think the way to look at this
is that when someone moves into a
Community Association they have certain
expectations they know there's a
guidelines for
uh the appearance of property for uh
rules and regulations that they must
abide by and what this bill seeks to do
is to undo all of that and give certain
uh people who engage in a certain hobby
rights that Trump all the rights under
the governing documents
owners are given the right to use common
area for their own purpose whether or
not the board agrees with that and and
gives gives that owner rights that are
superior to other owners uh at the
condominium it it sort of flips
condominium living uh on its head if you
will because instead of the board being
in control it's it's a single unit
owner I think there are serious
constitutional issues with the bill uh I
think there's property taking issues
when you're allowing an owner to acquire
common area for his or her own use and I
think you are vitiating uh the condo
docs as a private contract
you're you're changing the terms of
these pre-existing uh private contracts
between um unit owners at the
condominium um for example uh under the
uh proposed statute um an antenna up to
33 feet high can be installed without
prior approv approval uh I think that
would be upsetting to the the great many
the great majority of of most any condo
uh Community if suddenly an owner
installed that without uh prior
approval the uh statute also says that
if um an owner installs an antenna on
limited common area the board um would
have mere uh easement rights to fix
limited common area uh if it had to done
so instead of the condo association
owning The Limited common area as common
as because it is common area all of a
sudden they only have easement rights
because this limited common area has
been used uh to house an antenna so I
think um it really does trample the
rights of condo associations and and
upends all the con all the expectations
one has about living in a Community
Association and for all those reasons
and the reasons stated by Gary
I vigorously uh oppose this
bill okay so uh and and simar uh please
uh go online U and uh and log in and
register and also uh you know if if you
can put your testimony in in informed
that would be great to have that on file
for us I would be happy to thank you
very much okay now I see no more
hands and so uh we are definitely pass
our time um I would um I would would
read the blue list but um I was um it
blew up my my uh my printer so there's
um probably a hundred names on here not
that I knew any of the names but I
assume that these people were probably
all ham radio operators but maybe not I
don't know um so we this list will be uh
uploaded be in the file so if you if you
folks want to see who all the member all
these people who um who wait in and and
support of the bill so with that I will
close the public hearing um on House
Bill
313 thank you Mr chair thank
you all right um so we're we're a little
late here right now we're too yeah so
we're behind schedule now oh my God all
right all right so next is uh we're
going to go to rela uh the house bill
one 66 relative safety requirements for
pools on foreclosed Residential
Properties and I'll ask uh the sponsor
to raise your hand or anybody else who
uh who who
um wants to Bill and there there's Pat
all right Perfect all right represent
Ramy I am now moving you to the panelist
and you are to speak good afternoon
representative bromy
chairman uh for the record State Rep P
bramy Rockingham 19 town of stratum you
speak a little louder I know my my for
summaries and my was having problem in
ways and means a little bit ago about
this so um can you hear me a little
better now I'll just speak closer to the
uh it's it's very low so speak speak I'm
gonna have to be assertive all right
apologize for that um I'm here to
introduce House Bill 166 relative to
safety requirements for pools on for
foreclosed property uh it's a simple
bill which requires the pool cover be
placed over a pool of a foreclosed
residential property unoccupied for 60
days or
more this this is a uh a bill that was
filed last
year uh the bill came out of committee
Comm with overwhelming support and it it
was passed on the floor on a Voice vote
with no debate on the
bill then when it went over to the
Senate it uh it was not heard and it
there was no hearing and it was tabled
along with hundreds of other bills that
met the same demise last
year uh so I refiled
it uh last year I had the back the
backing of the New Hampshire Bankers
Association uh Ryan hail who's their
government Affairs
person uh and I did reach out to Ryan
hopefully he's on the list I don't know
uh I I don't have access to I can't see
the participant list from
here uh and U he actually helped me
amend the bill a little bit uh the last
line of the bill
says uh this requirement shall not apply
to any surface waters on the property
including but not limited to water
courses lakes ponds marshes or titled
Waters he just wanted that assurance and
the bankers Association supported the
bill then um I filed this bill at the
request of Luke picket my my constituent
from stratum who was a real in a real
estate
business uh Mr picket should be on the
list yes to speak okay great and I I
suggest Mr uh Mr chair that you hear
from him next
and to spare you all me an Ask answering
questions that he would probably do a
better job of answering and catch up on
time unless unless Mr chair you have a
pressing question of me uh I I'm I'm
also in Ways and Means at the moment on
Zoom right if you want a question or two
of me I'll I'll take it but it'll be
redundant of what Mr picket would say
but okay it's up to you yeah just to
make sure I remember this this bill did
not come to Commerce it went to it must
have gone to another I think it went to
Judiciary Judiciary is my understanding
representative burough is from that
committee so she probably remembers the
issue okay so all right well thank you
very much and go back I guess the only
thing I'll say is that U for for uh
properties that were um uh mortgage fed
and Fanny requires this uh this type of
requirement you'll hear that from uh
from uh Mr Mr picket great okay all
right thank you thank you all right so
uh Mr picket you have been promoted to a
panelist so all you have to do is unmute
and there you done that so good
afternoon good afternoon can you hear me
okay yes we
can uh thank you for uh letting me
attend uh as
uh uh Pat said we uh we came before I
guess it was the J Judiciary Committee
not sure why it was but uh uh last year
and uh presented this uh in essence uh
it's a uh it's an attempt to eliminate
uh an attractive nuisance uh in uh
neighborhoods and communities where a um
an unattended uh unoccupied home has a a
pool uh out out back uh that uh as uh I
think anybody can imagine uh unattended
or un unoccupied uh residents tend to uh
be attractive to uh um kids
and uh uh uncovered pools um uh either
uncovered or un netted pools uh can be
um can be extremely dangerous especially
at night
um uh as Pat said the uh this is uh
required by certain lenders uh we
approached the bankers Association last
year uh and they uh they fully supported
it I was very pleased with that I have
both a bank background and uh am
currently a real estate
uh real estate agent primarily on the
commercial side uh but understand this
uh being being an issue on the
residential side as well so um again it
is a a a a practical
simple um attempt uh for lenders uh to
protect communities and neighborhoods
from um an unnecessary uh attractive
nuisance uh for um for
kids great thank you uh is there any
member wants to ask a
question uh I guess not I guess it's
straightforward
enough um anybody in the committee room
I forgot to ask
them not that I can see you but it's all
right all right well thank you very much
I guess we're all set and uh I have uh
promoted William mckenny thank you thank
you for testifying I have promoted will
mcken to the panelist
and you uh you are free to uh testify Mr
mckin yes good afternoon uh chairman
hunt I appreciate you uh hearing me tday
I'm William mckin I'm a the president of
New Hampshire building officials
Association and and at this current time
we have no position on this bill um but
I do have four questions if we could get
some answers to that would help us um
come to a position on on this bill um we
weren't familiar with in legislation
last year um but it did come up on our
list to to watch this year um if you're
unfamiliar with the Hampshire building
officials Association we are primarily
An Education Association professional
association for code officials building
fire license design professionals and
contractors and educating them on code
building and fire code and zoning
ordinances in the state of New Hampshire
um the four questions if I may uh Mr
chairman are first off um we're
concerned and we don't understand what
the purpose of the pool covers are and
uh what issue are we trying to
correct um would you like me to do all
four questions now uh sure why don't you
do the four questions set the problem is
is you're posing them to us and just
you're you know theoretically they would
we would be asking the sponsor to do
this so so Luke I know you're still
there um and muted which is appre appi
it so uh what I would ask is is that you
posed your for question and then we can
have Luke come back and and respond to
them thank you very much Mr chairman um
our second question is um who is
expected to enforce the pool cover
requirement that's a big concern from
the code officials in the State uh third
question is who is responsible for
tracking of the foreclosures and making
sure that the pool covers are installed
and our fourth question is there's
already requirements for pool
protection um requiring guards and
barriers for pools um already in place
in RSA
155a and specifically the international
school and uh
International Spa and Pool code um
section
305 um and we're just concerned we just
want to make sure that we're not having
conflicts between something that's
already in legislation now um and what's
proposed in this
legislation so I would actually guess
that the that that fourth question
really goes back to your first question
is where's the problem what's exactly
the problem trying to solve if we
already have a um zoning or not zoning
it's a building code requirement that
all swimming pools have to have a fence
around them anyways correct yes sir
perfect okay um Mr picket uh would you
like to respond to those questions yes
uh uh so I guess
um uh first and four are are are
somewhat related uh the purpose of the
pool cover is to actually pool cover or
pool net is to actually cover the pool
itself um uh
fences uh are uh are typically not
barriers to entry especially when a home
is unattended uh or or or unoccupied um
when I was a teenager we used to refer
to it as pool hopping and it was really
fence hopping um all fences have have
always been in place and uh they're not
they're not new uh but we uh they were
uh they are not a significant
significant barrier to uh problems the
purpose of the pool cover or pool net is
to actually secure the surface of the
pool itself whether it be full or empty
uh even an empty pool is dangerous
because people can fall follow in fall
in hit their head uh and with just a
little bit of uh uh water at the bottom
could also be an issue so it's actually
to secure I hate to say this to you but
you really need to keep straight because
every time you turn sideways we lose you
so I'm sorry so your microphone is very
centered on you
okay
um uh who is expected to enforce it I
would uh uh not really uh thought about
that but it would be to me it would be
logical to have uh that enforcement be
local just as uh while an occupied home
is required to have a uh a fence uh
whoever would uh
would recognize or observe locally
whether a pool has a um has a fence on
it would also be uh would also be the uh
the individual or group responsible for
identifying whether a uh foreclosed home
is um uh is uh has a pool cover or pool
net on it and then in terms of tracking
I believe when a home is foreclosed upon
uh title changes and uh the taxing
Authority is uh is noticed when when
that title occur uh change occurs and
therefore the local municipality and I
would imagine the local enforcement uh
are housed in the same same building so
uh I think that change of ownership
would uh would be triggered locally or
would be identified locally as well
which which sounds like the code
enforcement the town's code enforcer
should that would be my logic that's
where I would see it as as logically
Landing yes sir okay great um okay uh
now I know this is a little awkward
because I had um somebody else asking
the question so uh so
um terms of the the our code enforc did
did you have any other questions to be
asked or is every
Everybody you okay with that or did he
take him oh you know what I I might have
pulled him
out I'm sorry pop your hand back up if
you would like if you have any more
questions otherwise we'll
assume uh uh we're all set okay all
right so we have I'm I guess we're all
set um and and uh so so
uh uh do I have anybody else so thank
you very much um Mr pcket and and Bill
mckin did respond or did get a questions
he got his questions in answered uh so
is there anybody else who like questions
are you able to hear me Mr CH you are
there you are okay yes there was a pro
problem with my microphone I don't
believe okay well this case you I needed
you to raise your hand but I probably
didn't say that but okay go now that
wrong hand is
my my rais handing disappeared on me too
I'm having all kinds of problems okay
okay right yeah I I would actually you
know um request that you know possibly
the sponsor of this bill and myself can
have a conversation on this after the
meeting just to address a couple of
concerns that urge you to do that yes
that would be wonderful I please thank
you we appreciate it thank you so that's
great um okay now anybody else who would
like to raise their hand or weigh in on
this piece of legislation okay good um
on the public hearing on the blue sheet
we had Eric uh
wrathman um who support uh who supports
the bill and then of course Ryan hail
who was mentioned before the New
Hampshire Bankers Association also in
support of the bill and with that we
will close the public hearing on um
House Bill 166 and thank you all for
testimony now how we doing for time 2:30
so we're all right so we're we're almost
caught
up
and so I guess I would ask the sponsors
of uh 473 to raise their hand so that I
can I can
then uh okay there there we go uh and
represent Jenkin okay so I'm going to
have you promoted to panelists there you
go uh good
afternoon representative
jenan here we go there we go thank you
Mr chairman I'm for the record I'm
representative John janigian Rockingham
District 8 Saleem New Hampshire um um
today I want to introduce uh HB 473
which establishes a renters insurance
notification
requirements um with this bill I
introduced the last time in a different
bill number made a couple of changes
I'll explain the reason for it and then
I'll tell you what the minor changes are
that might make it more palatable uh
this bill basically requires a landlord
of a residential rental property that is
rented for a duration of longer than one
month to include within the rental
agreement just a simple sentence or two
that informs the tenant that the
landlord's insurance does not cover
that's the landlord's property insurance
insurance does not cover the tenant's
belongings from loss or damage and that
the landlord recommends the tenant they
don't have to but the tenant purchase
their own insurance at their own cost
what is the point to this bill well the
major the major point to it is and I've
been a landlord by the way for over 30
years I've noticed that probably at
least half the tenants coming in have no
idea about renters insurance they just
figure well something happens the
landlords I don't know if they even
think about it and it's typically
younger tenants that would fall into
this category maybe firsttime tenants
and younger
tenants uh but there's many instances
where tenants property has been damaged
and they lose everything and there's no
way they can recover it if they don't
have insurance and sometimes it can end
up in landlord tenant disputes where the
tenant is mad or upset that why didn't
the landlord tell them or why isn't it
covered or or whatever so this tries to
help set that expectation and and to
minimize the issues in that Realm
um and I and I'm there's also I mean I I
can't see the list but U there's a
there's at least one other person um
Diane pette who will be talking I
believe um from Salem and she's she's
helped um several fire uh we had a
couple major fires in Salem where many
tenants lost their their belongings and
none of them had insurance so it's it's
it is something that would really help
it a lot of landlords probably already
have a sentence like this in but many
landlords still do not and one of the
things that makes this simpler than last
time is there was there was two concerns
that I remember last time one was
landlords were worried that they'd have
to go back and fix all the previous
rental agreements so this HB 473
explicitly says it's only only required
for new rental agreements going forward
and written rental agreements because I
also had some people who are worried
well what if you have tenant situations
where there's oral agreements maybe
someone's renting a room in a house and
things like this so we take all that off
the table too and tried to simplify this
to the point where hopefully it's pable
and um you know obviously if there's any
other changes I'm open to other changes
as well but with that I'll I'll stop uh
talking and and if anyone has any
questions for me I'll try to answer them
to the best of my knowledge hey right uh
representative van
hton thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative um I remember some
heart-wrenching testimony last session
by people who lost everything uh and and
we all know that people can can lose
more than everything they can lose life
as well so this is an important issue
and I am a former by the way Mr chairman
I am a former land baroness I am no
longer in the land bearness category um
so I I do have a kind of an on the
ground running
sense of what it's like for new young
people to to rent and not be aware of
everything my concern is that this is a
sentence that informs them my question
therefore is isn't this more of an
education issue than a legislative
issue um it's it's potentially a
education issue but it's this is
actually the third time this bill's been
being brought up and it doesn't seem
like the education piece is getting out
there um so it's that's why I felt the
need to bring it up in a in a bill
again thank you well set okay
representative
gson now thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr janigan um I I guess what I'm
want to make sure is is all that is you
are seeking in this legislation is a
statement in the lease agreement that
the the uh the the Les e would just
acknowledge uh some something similar to
no pets on the property and if you have
a pet in violation you're acknowledging
you're not going to have a pet or no
smoking on the premises acknowledging
that and then the next line item might
be uh my homeowner's policy does not
cover your personal possession so I
recommend if you want coverage you would
get your own insurance policy is that it
and there's no cost no no cost to the to
the to the landlord no cost to the
tenant um well well no well there's no
cost to the landlord of course there's a
cost to the tenant if they want to get
rent oh there's no cost cost no cost
this legislation does not impose a cost
on either the tenant or the landlord
just to at least say do you understand
boom exactly yes
yeah okay uh representative Barrow thank
you and thank you for taking my question
I'm just trying to understand I give you
a scenario to see if this bill would
impact it let's say that somebody's
belongings were um there was a flood and
the person's belongings were you know
totally destroyed because of the flood
but the flood was the result of of a
negligence on the part of the landlord
does this bill impact that them being
responsible for that property in any
way who uh well not being a lawyer that
that that'd be a tough one for me to
answer however um you know I'm trying to
imagine that scenario because I am a
landlord um I mean I
think negligence is one of those things
where negligence doesn't protect you
from anything so uh if I'm a negligent
landlord not cleaning snow and ice away
and somebody slips and Falls
um then and and and I and this tenant
didn't explicitly say they were
responsible for the ice and snow then I
could be responsible through a court
action um so I don't see where this gets
rid of
negligence um as an issue I'm not sure
any any any law if it gets rid of
negligence um but I'm not a lawyer I
don't know if there's a lawyer in in the
group that could answer that but I don't
I don't think that would stop follow up
please for the question meire yeah do
you think then that this law might
somehow communicate to tenants that the
landlord was off the hook for any kind
of
responsibility in all in these kinds of
scenarios no I don't think so this is
very specific we're talking about
renters insurance for their belongings
um I I think it's I think it I think
it's very clear I don't think that would
be an issue thank
you okay uh thank you uh representative
Barlett thank you very much Mr chair um
I had 35 years in
Insurance negligence is roughly
equivalent to liability so if a landlord
so um how do I make this a question
would you believe that if a landlord is
as representative you gave for um an
example uh was negligent in clearing off
snow and someone's injured then their
policy would respond to that type of an
injury um however if there you know
there are many other kinds of things
that insurance covers that would never
be covered under the property owner
insurance so that's why this
notification would really help renters
because in all my years of insurance
there are so many renters that have no
idea that they have no coverage for
their belongings or their their um
additional living expense if they were
actually out of the property that's all
thanks very much for bringing this spill
again thank you okay so is that the kids
voice was that is that behind you
Chrissy or no here okay so that's gone
okay great um all right I have see no
more oh I do have another hand here we
go representative
ham May
inquire yes thank you um Mr chair um I
am a landlord and and reading this
wearing that hat
it really does sound I think there needs
to be some clarification or added
language because it says a tenant
belongings from loss or damage and that
loss or damage could be my fault or it
could be it could be my furnace that
malfunctioned or it could be my roof
that leaked that
caused um the loss of your belongings
and I know and have experienced that in
the past I mean I would like this as a
landlord but from the tenants uh
perspective um it could be interpreted
by somebody that uh okay um my furnace
went my roof leaked all your ruin all
your belongings got ruined and I don't
have to pay so uh would you believe I
suggest there might be need for a a few
more words in here to make that
clear yeah I mean I'm I'm open to
additional Lang anguage however some of
the I'm I'm just thinking about what you
just said I mean if the roof leaks or
the the
furnace I mean blows up uh or you know
something in a way that damages things
those are those are I mean unless it's
again unless we're back to negligence
where the landlord would be responsible
for negligence but if these things just
happen um that's not necessarily the
land that's not the landlord's fault if
it's I me if I've been servicing a
furnace let's say I service any oil
burning F furnace every year if
something goes majorly wrong that causes
damage I mean what else could I have
done with that I'm I'm calling the
service guy every Year's he's servicing
it however if I'm if I'm never servicing
the furnace and and you know oil
furnaces should be serviced somewhere in
that I mean I do it every year but
somewhere in that time frame if you just
never do it and you're negligent and it
blows up and causes problems that that
that negligence then is um a wholly
different topic I I think you know
specifically here um I think this does
cover it but as I said I'm open to
hearing additional thoughts on
language okay thank you uh
representative van hton you have another
question I do thank you um while I'm
absolutely um sympathetic to this as a
as both an educator and as a landlord
who's who's rented to young people with
their first rental possibility um I I
just don't
know okay if I were still a landlord
today and I did not include this Clause
under the legislation that you proposed
would there be any ramifications for
me I haven't
um it's a good question I haven't um put
any uh penalty in the bill I mean as
it's as it's written there is no penalty
um and partly because my goal isn't here
to penalize landlords um it's to bring
awareness I mean once a bill like this
if this bill passes granted the
landlords
associations um are going to begin
putting out the word that you know make
sure that you have this have this in
there um but you know as the bill is
written there is no penalty for thank
you very much okay that's an interesting
question right that that circles the the
opposite they said if you don't put it
in is that mean you're liable
now because you didn't put it in the
contract into the lease would that could
someone then the tenant then sue you
because you didn't put it in but I don't
know again we don't we have to ask a
lawyer people who are experts on that
subject uh okay representative McClary
has a
question one of days we'll get there
right uh
uh representative uh J janigan I guess
here I am getting my name not pronounced
right and I'm doing the same thing I
apologize uh is there not a standard uh
uh tenant form in New Hampshire a
standard form that a landlord would use
I I see Christie saying there isn't I
would have thought there'd be a standard
form that that you could put this in but
I guess I got my answer well I mean
there's there's there's different forms
out there there's no yeah there's no
absolute standard that every landlord
uses um but um there are forms that
people can pull from various places and
uh my my guess is um if a lawyer writes
it up or or or somebody does have a
standard form it probably has this in it
um but you know the landlords that
aren't using standard forms or and
there's plenty of them um you know then
then they wouldn't the potential T
wouldn't be aware
um of
it right okay thank you um so I have
just promoted uh Rick blaze up to
panelist and so that he can testify
thank you much very much represent jenan
good afternoon again everybody um again
my name is Rick blae was on earlier
today I figured out the system it works
well um basically I ran a land ORD
Association for a couple of decades we
had over th000 members in it throughout
the state of New Hampshire here and
there's over tens of thousands of
landlords and the bill is good
intentions I do this with every tenant
every time I lease an
apartment and you're trying to legislate
Common Sense here you know education is
the big thing I think what you're trying
to do janigan you're trying to do is
educate the landlord to notify the
tenant legislation is a dangerous and
slippery slope here there is liability
for the landlord should the something
happen and that wasn't in their lease
now the tenant can come back and say you
never told me and now I'm in a lawsuit
situation I'm going to settle just so I
don't have to go to court which might
cost me 10 or
15,000 again in an affordable housing
situation I wear also an affordable
housing hat as a president on the board
of the way home I just see this as a
more of a reach we should be reaching
out to people not legislating to them
when it comes to this matter and if you
put some type of you know damages in
there or penalty in there now you got a
whole War happening from affordable
housing everybody's going to come out
screaming I just look at it as the the
intention of the bill I see the merits
of it but I don't think it should be a
legislation issue I I just think we I do
a good job I still even though I'm
retired from The Landlord Association I
still hold meetings where I have 40 or
50 landlords every other month coming
into classes I'm doing one for neighbor
Works in Manchester here on Saturday and
again I just try to bring Common Sense
the how do you run a business as a
landlord large or small and I think if
anything that's where the energy should
be put not so much in a legislation like
this but I appreciate all you guys do
and the intent here thank
you okay thank you does anybody have a
question for Mr
Blaze
and
I
guess guess we're all all
done all right um so on the blue sheet
uh I have Nicole
40 um who's a member of the public and
supports the bill Robert
best uh member of the public supporting
the bill uh Paul perini who is um the
New Hampshire State Fire Marshall's
office supports the bill uh Eric Ray
rman who's a member of the public
supports the bill and Josh
yoka uh is the State Rep representative
Y is opposed to the bill and
representative Rebecca McWilliams is
also opposed to the bill and with that
and I see no more hands up um we will
end the public hearing on House Bill
473 and for the members before you all
uh leave us um whether you were he at
the beginning of the meeting or not um
that I will be scheduling uh coming
forward uh the remain uh for we have
four days won't take care of all the
bills but it'll certainly make a big cut
in it so next week February 2nd and
February 3rd Tuesday and Wednesday then
the following week February 9th and
February 10th um and we will be having
our public uh hearings and that I would
hope on February 3
uh that we can um take care of those two
early bills that we have so if you have
any comments or anything like that
please feel free to con contact me and
representative Herbert you have a
question Chris did you did tally raise
your hand or did you not mean to do
that yeah there you
go I keep waiting for you to do it for
me I think is what's going on but uh zec
uh did I hear you correctly that we're
going to do uh you're going to try
Thursday to do some exacts Wednesday
February 3 Wednesday February 3D yeah
that I would like to try I would like to
try to exact those two early bills that
we
have okay thank you
yeah and all right now I will lower your
hand
Chris that that I'm willing to do for
you turning your mic on and off I'm
trying to whole lot on that okay is
anybody else has uh anything else they
want to
share otherwise uh we will see you all
again next week and I think this worked
out well and had a good day good job
okay take care everybody bye-bye